Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. This night, for the first time, Polish regular soldiers fired on our territory. Since 5.45am, we have been returning their fire, and from now on bombs will be met by bombs. Whoever fights with poison gas will be fought with poison gas. Whoever departs from the rules of humane warfare can only expect that we shall do the same. And I will continue this struggle against any enemy until the safety and rights of the Reich are secured. I am asking no more of any German than what I did myself for four years. There
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest is History）。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社团，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。今晚，波兰正规军首次向我们的领土开火。自清晨5点45分起，我们一直在进行反击，从现在开始，我们将以炸弹回击炸弹。谁使用毒气作战，我们也将用毒气回击。任何背离人道主义战争规则的人，只能期待我们做出同样的举动。我将继续这场与任何敌人的斗争，直到帝国的安全和权利得到保障。我没有对任何德国人提出比我自己四年亲身经历更多的要求。这里
will be no hardships that I do not share. From this moment on, my entire life belongs to my people. I want nothing else now than to be the first soldier of the German Reich. I have now put on the same uniform that was once so dear, so sacred to me. I will only take it off when victory is won or else I will not live to see it. So Dominic, the unmistakable tones there of Adolf Hitler, and he was addressing the Reichstag on the 1st of September, 1939. And this was on the occasion of the declaration of war on Poland, which in effect, I know that historians of China may disagree, but let's run with this. It's basically the outbreak of the second
将没有任何苦难是我所不曾分担的。从这一刻起，我的一切都属于我的国民。现在，我别无所求，只愿成为德意志帝国的第一士兵。我穿上了曾经对我如此亲切、如此神圣的同一套军服。只有在胜利到来时我才会脱下它，否则我将无法活着看到那一天的到来。所以，多米尼克，刚才那是阿道夫·希特勒标志性的语气，他在1939年9月1日向国会对发表了讲话。这是在对波兰宣战之际发表的，实际上——我知道研究中国历史的学者可能会有不同意见，但我们姑且这么认为——这基本上就是第二
world war. And I gave him there, you know, doing his kind of rant, people on YouTube were able to see me gesticulating and all of that frothing. But actually, he was quite hesitant really, wasn't he? He kind of occasionally stumbled over his words, seemed a bit nervous. You know, he's been looking forward to this great moment. And now when it's come, I mean, is there kind of a slight measure of doubt? There is, I think, a lot of stress. I think Hitler's not the devil. He's a human being. He's made of flesh and blood. And at this crucial moment in his career, the moment that his life, his political career has been building towards, the outbreak of the war in Europe that he's been
次世界大战的爆发。刚才我模仿了他那种慷慨激昂的样子，YouTube上的观众可以看到我手舞足蹈、唾沫横飞。但实际上，他当时相当犹豫，不是吗？他偶尔会结巴，看起来有点紧张。你知道的，他一直期盼着这个伟大的时刻。现在时刻终于到来，难道他内心真的有一丝怀疑吗？我认为，压力确实很大。希特勒并非恶魔，他是一个人。他也是血肉之躯。在他职业生涯的这个关键时刻，在他的人生和政治生涯一直为之积蓄力量的时刻，在欧洲战争爆发的这一刻——他为此预言了
predicting for so long, I think he's in a bit of an emotional state, actually. He's in a bit of a mess because he doesn't know whether Britain and France are going to enter the war or not. Everything is in play. Yeah, he actually got the time wrong. He said 545, but it was actually 445. He stumbled there and said the wrong time. He was very, very hesitant and with good reason.
如此之久，实际上他的情绪处于一种相当微妙的状态。他一团糟，因为他不知道英法两国是否会参战。一切都充满变数。是的，他其实把时间记错了。他说的是5点45分，但实际上是4点45分。他在那里结巴了，说错了时间。他非常非常犹豫，而且情有可原。
This is the moment that he throws the dice and we all know what the consequences for Europe will be, but also the consequences for Hill himself. He looks ahead there to his own death. I won't take this uniform off unless either victory is won or I am dead. And he's already, I think, anticipating what he will do if things go wrong, i.e. the Wagnerian fate. Yeah, dead at the funeral pyre of his capital. Exactly.
这是他孤注一掷的时刻，我们都知道这对欧洲意味着什么，同时也知道对希特勒本人意味着什么。他在那里预见了自的死亡。除非取得胜利，或者我死去，否则我不会脱下这件军服。而且我认为，他已经在预料如果事情搞砸了自己会怎么做，也就是瓦格纳式的命运。是的，死于他首都的葬身火海之中。没错。
So this is the second episode of our trilogy about the Nazi war on Poland. And we ended last time, Tom, as you may remember, with Hitler and his generals drawing up their plan of attack on the 11th of April 1939. The Poles have resisted their attempts to persuade them to give up Danzig and to turn themselves into a satellite state. So he's drawn up this plan for an attack on Poland. And it's about the same time in April that Joachim von Ribbentrop, very much not somebody admired by the rest of history, it's fair to say, for all kinds of reasons, sartorial and ideological. Toby Sofowicz Tailoring, I think, high on the list.
所以，这是我们关于纳粹对波兰战争三部曲的第二集。汤姆，你可能还记得，上一次我们结束时，希特勒和他的将领们在1939年4月11日制定了进攻计划。波兰人拒绝了他们关于放弃但泽并把自己变成卫星国的劝说。因此，他制定了这份进攻波兰的计划。大约也是在4月份，约阿希姆·冯·里宾特洛普——无论从服装还是意识形态等各方面原因来看，可以说他绝对不是一个受到《历史的余烬》其他人所赞赏的人——托比·索福维茨（Toby Sofowicz）定制服装，我觉得名列前茅。
Richard Sofowicz Tailoring very high on the list. But he suggests an idea that on paper seems completely unthinkable, which is why don't we do a deal with our ideological arch enemy Stalin and divide up Poland between us. And we'll be following that story in today's episode. But the man you've been ventriloquizing there in an impression that may get you cancelled is kind of hard to tell, isn't it? I don't think so. You don't think so? No. I think there was a lot of gusto there.
理查德·索福维茨（Richard Sofowicz）定制服装名列前茅。但他提出了一个在纸面上看起来完全不可思议的想法，那就是为什么我们不跟我们的意识形态死敌斯大林做个交易，把波兰瓜分呢？我们将在今天的节目中讲述这个故事。不过，你刚才用腹语模仿的那个人，可能会让你遭到“取消文化”的抵制，真真假假很难说，不是吗？我不觉得。你不觉得吗？不觉得。我觉得刚才很有气势。
Well, I mean, I think if you're conveying a sense of Hitler's manic, demonic energy, you've got to go for it. You've got to go for it, haven't you? I suppose you do. Yeah, I suppose you do. I mean, it's important to feel what's motivating and driving him, or else you don't understand the war. Yeah, method acting.
好吧，我的意思是，如果你要传达希特勒那种狂躁、恶魔般的能量，你就必须豁出去。你必须全力以赴，对吧？我想你是对的。是的，我想是的。我的意思是，去感受是什么在激励和驱动他是很重要的，否则你就无法理解这场战争。是的，体验派表演。
Anyway, Hitler himself, right, he's 50 years old. He had celebrated his 50th birthday on the 20th of April, 1939. So just nine days after the plan was drawn up for the destruction of Poland. And to mark the big day, I mean, it is one of the most extraordinary birthday parties in the history, Goebbels organized what Ian Kershaw, Hitler's great biographer called an astonishing extravaganza of the Fuhrer cult. So they have a huge parade of limousines down this new road, this new avenue in Berlin called the East West Axis,
不管怎样，希特勒本人，对吧，他50岁了。他在1939年4月20日庆祝了自己的50岁生日。也就是制定毁灭波兰计划仅仅九天之后。为了庆祝这个大日子，戈培尔组织了一场希特勒伟大传记作家伊恩·克肖（Ian Kershaw）所称的“元首崇拜的惊人盛会”，这可以说是历史上最非同寻常的生日派对之一。因此，他们在柏林这条被称为“东西轴心”的新道路、新大道上举行了盛大的豪华轿车游行，
which has been planned as the main boulevard of the new capital of Germania. Berlin will be renamed in time Germania. That's Hitler's plan. And this is what Hitler's been chatting about with Albert Speer. Yeah, interminably. Yeah, drawing up little plans and big domes and things. Exactly. They have huge torch lit parades. And at midnight, so the moment basically that Hitler's birthday begins, Speer presents him with a big model for the new triumphal arch that they are planning, which would be the biggest triumphal arch in the world.
这条大道原本计划成为新首都“日耳曼尼亚”的主干道。柏林将来会被改名为日耳曼尼亚。这就是希特勒的计划。这也是希特勒一直与阿尔伯特·施佩尔谈论的内容。是的，没完没了地谈。是的，画一些小图纸和巨大的圆顶建筑之类的。没错。他们举行了盛大的火炬游行。在午夜，也就是希特勒生日开始的那一刻，施佩尔向他赠送了一个他们正在规划的新凯旋门的大模型，这将是世界上最大凯旋门。
Yes, so much bigger than the Arte Trio. Exactly. And then the next day, there's a gigantic military parade, a five-hour military parade, and Hitler stands, you know, he doesn't sit down, he stands and watches the whole thing and he's clearly delighted. And again, this is a reminder of how strange Hitler is, because I think for most dictators, this would be the apotheosis, the climax. You've turned 50, you've conquered, you know, everything. You've, you've achieved all the foreign policy goals of any German nationalist, pretty much. This is the point to stop and slow down and, and enjoy it.
是的，比凯旋门大得多。没错。然后第二天，有一场宏大的阅兵式，一场持续五个小时的阅兵式，希特勒就那样站着——他没有坐下，他就那样站着看完整场活动，显然非常高兴。再次提醒我们希特勒是多么怪异，因为我想对大多数独裁者来说，这将是顶峰，是高潮。你已经50岁了，你征服了，你知道，一切。你基本上实现了任何德国民族主义者的所有外交政策目标。这是该停下来、慢下来并享受这一切的时候了。
And also you're not well, are you? You're necking quantities of gun oil. Yes, that's right. You're popping amphetamines. Yeah, absolutely. But as Ian Kershaw points out, 50 is an age where a lot of people tend to take stock. It's your classic kind of midlife crisis moment. So his midlife crisis is starting the second world war. I mean, of people tend to take stock. It's your classic kind of midlife crisis moment. So his midlife crisis is starting the second world war. I mean, some people go to the
而且你身体也不好，对吧？你狂吞大量的枪油。是的，没错。你在嗑安非他命。是的，绝对的。但正如伊恩·克肖所指出的那样，50岁是一个许多人倾向于进行反思的年龄。这是典型的中年危机时刻。所以他的中年危机就是发动第二次世界大战。我的意思是，有的人会去
gym, some people buy a red motorbike, other people start world conflicts. Well, that's Hitler, as Kershaw said. He spends all the time thinking about his own approaching death. Death is on his mind all the time. He has a sense of loss of vigor, great anxiety about his health, and this tremendous sense of time running out. It's really about his health, and this tremendous sense of time running out. It's really important to him to strike soon. Most of his high command are ultimately desperate to avoid war with the West because they think, why gamble everything? Why risk everything when we've achieved so much? We're in power. We enjoy being in power. We don't want to throw that away. That's what that's how most
健身，有的人买一辆红色的摩托车，而另一些人则挑起世界冲突。好吧，这就是希特勒，正如克肖所说。他把所有时间都用来思考自己即将到来的死亡。死亡随时都在他脑海中。他有一种活力丧失的感觉，对自己的健康有着极大的焦虑，并且有一种强烈的时间快要用完的感觉。对他来说，尽快动手非常重要。他的大部分高级指挥官最终都极力避免与西方开战，因为他们想：为什么要孤注一掷？当我们已经取得了如此大的成就时，为什么要冒一切风险？我们掌权了。我们喜欢掌权。我们不想扔掉这一切。大多数
authoritarians and dictators think. Not Hitler. He must have his war. So eight days after his birthday, he gives a landmark speech at the Reichstag. He renounces the non-aggression pact with Poland. So Tom, this is picking up your point
独裁者和专制者都是这么想的。希特勒可不这么想。他必须要他的战争。所以在他的生日八天后，他在国会发表了一场具有里程碑意义的演讲。他废除了与波兰的互不侵犯条约。所以，汤姆，这回应了你上一次关于这些条约有什么价值的观点？
from last time about what are these pacts worth? The answer is nothing. He also tears up the naval treaty with Britain. And for the first time he publicly lays out the grievances that he and Ribbentrop have prepared. So that's Danzig, which we heard about last time and the Polish corridor.
答案是毫无价值。他还撕毁了与英国的海军条约。并且他首次公开列出了他和里宾特洛普准备好的不满。那就是我们上次听说的但泽和波兰走廊。
And then a month goes by and he summons his commanders to the Reich chancellery and he gives them the full Adolf Hitler bingo card. So we're being strangled economically. We need more living space, our racial destiny, all of this kind of stuff. Jews? Yeah, the Jews are behind everything, of course. He says Poland is the target, absolutely, there will be war. But here he goes beyond anything that he has said to his generals before. For the first time, he does not talk, he explicitly rules out in fact, a friendship or alliance with the other Anglo-Saxon Germanic world power, which is Britain or England as he always
接着一个月过去了，他召集他的指挥官们来到帝国总理府，发表了阿道夫·希特勒式的全套经典言论。所以我们正在遭受经济绞杀。我们需要更多生存空间，我们的种族命运，所有这些东西。犹太人？是的，犹太人当然是一切的幕后黑手。他说波兰是目标，绝对的，战争将会爆发。但在这里，他超越了以往对将领们所说的一切。他第一次没有谈论、甚至明确排除了与另一个盎格鲁-撒克逊日耳曼世界大国（即英国，或者他总是称之为英格兰）的
calls it. He had always talked in the long run about some kind of deal with England. That basically was part of his vision. Germany rules Europe. Exactly. And what had been Russia and Britain rules the rest of the world basically. Exactly. But now for the first time, he says explicitly, England is our enemy and the showdown with England is a matter of life and death. So he's already beginning to recalibrate his
友谊或同盟。他过去总是谈到长远来看要与英国达成某种交易。这基本上是他的愿景的一部分。德国统治欧洲。没错。曾经的俄国和英国基本上统治世界其余地方。没错。但现在他第一次明确表示，英国是我们的敌人，与英国的决裂是生死攸关的问题。所以他已经开始把注意力从东方稍微重新校准到西方，也将西方视为一个意识形态上的死敌。
attention a little bit from the East towards the West to see the West as an ideological arch enemy as well. And for the first time, we have a preview of what's going to happen in 1940. He says, you know, I've been thinking about this a lot. We will have to take Holland and Belgium. We'll take France. We can easily take France. Of course, he is right. They do easily take France. But to his generals, it's mad, isn't it? Because on the Western border, Germany is outnumbered 61 by the French. Yeah. And as we will see in next week's episode, as the war begins, there is a
并且我们第一次预先看到了1940年将要发生的事情。他说，你知道的，我对此深思熟虑过。我们必须占领荷兰和比利时。我们要占领法国。我们能轻而易举地占领法国。当然，他是对的。他们的确轻而易举地占领了法国。但对他的将领们来说，这太疯狂了，不是吗？因为在西部边境，德国在人数上被法国人以六比一的比例压倒。正如我们在下周的节目中所看到的，战争爆发时，有一种
case that, you know, if the French had shown a little bit more gumption. Had gone in, gone in hard. Yeah. That would have been a very different outcome. But he says, we can take France. We'll take the Atlantic seaboard and the channel, and that will allow us to blockade England, we'll strangle England and bring them to their knees. The only question in his mind is the timetable.
情况是，你知道的，如果法国人表现出更多一点的魄力。果断出击，狠狠地打。是的。那将是一个非常不同的结果。但他说，我们可以占领法国。我们将占领大西洋海岸线和海峡，这将使我们能够封锁英国，我们将扼杀英国并让他们屈服。他脑海中唯一的疑问是时间表。
I think at this point, he's still thinking we do Poland this year and then maybe the West, Western Europe in a couple of years' time. But so he doesn't think that invading Poland will bring Britain and France into the war because he despises them as little worms, their leaders. And that will run through today's episode. His misjudgment, Hitler has judged his foreign policy coups very cleverly up to this point. But I think from this point on, or rather from the final attack on Czechoslovakia
我想在这个时候，他仍然在想我们今年搞定波兰，然后可能在几年后再对付西方、西欧。所以他不认为入侵波兰会让英法卷入战争，因为他鄙视他们的领导人，认为他们是微不足道的虫豸。而这一点将贯穿今天的节目。他严重的误判——希特勒在此之前一直非常巧妙地利用他的外交政变。但我认为从这个时候开始，或者确切地说，从我们上次谈到的对捷克斯洛伐克的最后一次进攻开始，从那时起，我认为他完全误读了伦敦。
that we did last time, from that point on, I think he completely misreads London. And do you think that's because he's actually met the British and French leaders in person? That's a good point. Actually. It's funny that he starts to get them wrong after he's met them. Yeah. I think that's part of it. I think vanity is part of it. He feels he was so affronted by Chamberlain and Chamberlain getting
你认为这是因为他实际上亲自见过英法领导人吗？这倒是个好观点。实际上。有趣的是，他在见过他们之后反而开始误解他们了。是的。我认为这是原因之一。我认为虚荣心也是一部分。他觉得自己被张伯伦羞辱得太厉害了，而且张伯伦在慕尼黑等等地方获得了掌声。他对张伯伦有着极大的个人蔑视，以至于他根本无法认真对待他。
applause in Munich and so on. And he has such personal contempt for Chamberlain that he just can't take him seriously at all. But also I think by this point, a Hitler's off his head on gun oil, but B, he has completely drunk the Fuhrer Kool-Aid. He now thinks all this business about I've been chosen by Providence. Yeah, he's all into that. You don't want to lead everything like that. I mean, that's mad. Anyway, that spring and summer Ribbentrop's diplomats lay the foundations. They make all these more non-aggression pacts, which as you will know, Tom, are worthless
但我也认为到这个时候，A，希特勒满脑子都是枪油；B，他完全喝下了元首库尔爱德毒酒（盲目相信元首神话）。他现在满脑子都是诸如“我是天命所归”之类的事情。是的，他完全迷陷于此。你可不想让那种事情领导一切。我的意思是，那太疯狂了。无论如何，那个春夏季节，里宾特洛普的外交官们打下了基础。他们缔结了所有这些更多的互不侵犯条约——汤姆，正如你所知，这些条约对丹麦人、拉脱维亚人、爱沙尼亚人来说是一文不值的。
with people like the Danes, the Latvians, the Estonians. We shall see, of course, what these non-aggression pacts are worth. He does a deal with Yugoslavia for its copper. He does a deal with Romania for its oil and its wheat. So these are clever deals. These are stocking up. It's like playing a board game. It is. And presumably the player that Hitler is on the other side of the
当然，我们将看到这些互不侵犯条约有什么价值。他与南斯拉夫就其铜矿达成交易。他与罗马尼亚就其石油和小麦达成交易。所以这些都是聪明的交易。这些都是在囤积物资。就像在玩棋盘游戏一样。确实是。而且可以想象，和希特勒在游戏棋盘另一边的玩家
game board is France, which is a country that has traditional links with a lot of these countries had tried to forge a kind of military alliance. But presumably in the wake of Munich is totally shot, no credibility left at all. And I wonder also whether by this point, there is a sense across most of Europe and maybe across most of the world that democracy itself is shot. Yeah, I think so. That fascism is the face of the future and that, you know, the democracies with their shabby leaders and their old-fashioned clothes are just heading towards a scrap heap of history.
是法国，这是一个与其中许多国家有着传统联系、并曾试图建立某种军事同盟的国家。但可以想象，在慕尼黑事件之后，法国已经彻底完蛋了，毫无信誉可言。我也在想，到这个时候，整个欧洲乃至整个世界是否有一种感觉，即民主本身已经完蛋了。是的，我想是的。法西斯主义是未来的面孔，你知道的，那些拥有寒酸领导人和老式服装的民主国家正走向历史的垃圾堆。
Totally, there is, Tom. I think you're absolutely right. I think that's been running through the 1930s within the democracies themselves, of course. All these bright young men at Cambridge who are Stalinists, for example. Yeah, they want to be on the right side of history. Chamberlain and de Ladier are not on the right side of history and Chamberlain and de Ladey are not on the right side of history. They look stuffy, they look boring, they look dithery, they look weak. And if you're, as you say, if you're a government in Eastern Europe looking for an ally, you say France really?
完全如此，汤姆。我想你绝对是对的。我认为这在20世纪30年代的民主国家内部一直存在，当然。剑桥的所有那些聪明年轻人都成了斯大林主义者，比如。是的，他们想站在历史正确的一边。张伯伦和达拉第并不在历史正确的一边，而张伯伦和达拉第并不在历史正确的一边。他们看起来古板、无聊、优柔寡断、软弱。如果你像你所说的那样，是东欧一个寻找盟友的政府，你会说：真的是法国吗？
I mean, they were great allies of Czechoslovakia and where are they now? Whereas you think Hitler wins, you know, he judges things correctly, he's decisive, he's strong. That's the calculation that a lot of these people are making. But also the ideology behind it, the image of strength and power that maybe this is the future. Yeah, seductive, it's glamorous, it seems modern. Exactly right. Exactly. Now one person who has a little bit ambivalent is Mussolini. Mussolini doesn't want a war at all, but he's basically tricked into signing the Pact of Steel, a renewed deepened military alliance.
我的意思是，他们曾是捷克斯洛伐克的伟大盟友，而现在他们在哪里？然而你认为希特勒会赢，你知道的，他判断事情很准确，他果断、强大。这就是许多这样的人正在做出的算计。但同时还有其背后的意识形态，即力量和权力的形象，也许这就是未来。是的，充满诱惑力，迷人，看起来很现代。完全正确。完全正确。现在有一个人态度有点矛盾，那就是墨索里尼。墨索里尼根本不想打仗，但他基本上被诱骗签署了《钢铁同盟》，这是一项重新恢复并深化的军事同盟。
I mean, honestly, I mean, if you're signing something called the Pact of Steel, you should know what you're getting yourself into. With a load of people who've got skull and crossbones on there. Yeah, I mean, you know, there are clues there. But Ribbentrop says to him, listen, don't worry. I mean, we're not thinking about war for five years, which is. I mean, you know, there are clues there. But Ribbentrop says to him, listen, don't worry. I mean, we're not thinking about war for five years, which is, I mean, that's all right then. And must say, he says, oh, well, fine, fair enough. Yeah, we'll do it. All that summer, Hitler does his usual trick that he'd done last time of basically trying
说实话，我的意思是，如果你签署了一份名为《钢铁同盟》的东西，你应该知道自己将卷入什么。上面还印着一堆骷髅和交叉骨头。是的，我的意思是，你知道的，那里有线索。但里宾特洛普对他说，听着，别担心。我的意思是，我们五年内不考虑战争，这。我的意思是，你知道的，那里有线索。但里宾特洛普对他说，听着，别担心。我的意思是，我们五年内不考虑战争，这，我的意思是，那倒也行吧。墨索里尼说，哦，好吧，很好，挺合理的。好吧，我们干吧。整个夏天，希特勒都在耍他上次用过的那套老把戏，基本上就是试图
to pretend that he hasn't got any military plans at all. So he just goes on a tour of his childhood haunts in Austria. He goes to Bayreuth to listen to Wagner. I know you're a great devotee of Wagner, aren't you, Tom? So again, a disturbing similarity. Another pointer of comparison. Yeah, exactly. He's got Unity Mitford with him. Yeah, and you love the Mitfords.
假装自己完全没有任何军事计划。所以他只是去奥地利他童年熟悉的地方进行了巡游。他去拜罗イト（Bayreuth）听瓦格纳的音乐会。我知道你是瓦格纳的超级狂热崇拜者，对吧，汤姆？所以又是一个令人不安的相似之处。又一个比较的线索。是的，exactly。他带着尤妮蒂·米特福德（Unity Mitford）同行。是的，你很喜欢米特福德家族。
Oh my God. It's all stacking up. And he goes to this huge festival of German culture in Munich, doesn't he? Which has become a kind of annual celebration of basically artworks. Who is it? There's an artist who's called the pubic hair artist or something, because he's always sculpting kind of nudes, German nudes. And Goebbels is all over this. And he goes there and Ogles, all the women who are wearing kind of exotic German costumes and things. It's all quite odd.
天哪。这一切都在堆积。他去慕尼黑参加了那个盛大的德国文化节，不是吗？这已经成为基本上是艺术品的一种年度庆祝活动。那是谁？有一个艺术家被称为“阴毛艺术家”之类的，因为他总是雕刻那种裸体，德国裸体。戈培尔对此全情投入。他去那里色迷迷地看着那些穿着奇特德国传统服饰等等的女人们。这一切都挺古怪的。
And of course he spends loads of time in the eagle's nest going for walks and like talking to Spear about triumphal arches and watching terrible films and stuff. Meanwhile, just as in the Czech crisis, Goebbels' propaganda machine is kind of has cranked up, pouring out all these grievances and what they will do just as in the Sudetenland, they'll take a genuine, often a local grievance with a grain of truth and then massively amplify and exaggerate it into a colossal injustice. So this time, remember last time it was a guy who was basically a PE teacher called Konrad Henlein. Yeah.
当然，他在鹰巢花了大量时间散步，和施佩尔谈论凯旋门，看糟糕的电影等等。与此同时，就像在捷克危机中一样，戈培尔的宣传机器已经全速运转，倾泻出所有这些不满以及他们将要做什么——正如在苏台德地区一样，他们会抓住一个真实的、通常是带有几分真实成分的地方怨恨，然后将其疯狂放大和夸大，变成一个巨大的不公。所以这一次，还记得上次那家伙基本上是个体育老师，叫康拉德·亨lein（Konrad Henlein）。是的。
And now there's a fellow called Albert Forster. He's the Nazi party chief in Danzig. He came from the same town, interestingly, as Henry Kissinger, called Fürth in Franconia. Kissinger, of course, a refugee from Nazi Germany. I mean, a huge part of Kissinger's makeup is that experience. Anyway, there's this huge stream of stories saying basically, ethnic Germans in Poland are being beaten up, they're being attacked, all of this kind of thing. Now, it is true that Poland has a much more nationalistic government than Czechoslovakia did. But as Richard Evans says in his book on the Third Reich, these stories are nevertheless massive exaggerations at best and complete inventions at worst. And what Forster's goons will do is they will
现在有个家伙叫阿尔伯特·福斯特（Albert Forster）。他是纳粹党在但泽的党魁。有趣的是，他与亨利·基辛格来自同一个小镇，名叫弗兰肯地区的菲尔特（Fürth）。基辛格当然是纳粹德国的难民。我的意思是基辛格性格的很大一部分都源于那种经历。不管怎样，有源源不断的故事说：波兰的德国少数族裔正在被殴打，他们正遭到袭击，诸如此类的事情。现在，波兰确实有一个比捷克斯洛伐克更具民族主义色彩的政府；但正如理查德·埃文斯在他的第三帝国著作中所说，这些故事往好了说是巨大的夸大，往坏了说是彻头彻尾的捏造。福斯特的手下会做的是，
stage provocations to try and get a Polish counter reaction. So they take a great offense at the fact that Poles have things like customs offices and post offices in Danzig and they're always claiming that Polish postmen and customs inspectors are kind of beating up Germans and all of this kind of thing. And the thing is that this has a very ready audience in Germany. We talked before, didn't we, in the Munich episodes about what ordinary Germans make of all this kind of thing. Do they believe it? And I think a lot of ordinary Germans absolutely swallow this stuff. They've been primed to swallow this actually by decades, if not centuries, of prejudice against the Poles.
他们会策动挑衅，试图引发波兰的反击。因此，他们对波兰人在但泽设有海关和邮局等事情感到非常冒犯，并且总是声称波兰邮递员和海关检查员在殴打德国人，诸如此类的事情。问题在于，这在德国有着非常现成的受众。我们之前在慕尼黑的那几集里谈过，普通德国人对所有这些事情有什么看法。他们相信吗？我认为许多普通德国人完全相信了这套说辞。他们实际上已经被长达数十年、甚至数个世纪的对波兰人的偏见灌输好了，准备好接受这一切了。
But I suppose Danzig is slightly different to say Austria or the state and land in that those were never part of Germany, whereas Danzig had been part of Germany. Yeah. So it'd be like for us, I don't know, Bournemouth was an open city or something. You'd think, hmm. I suppose. I mean, Danzig has, Danzig, there had been tough periods where Danzig had been Polish. So it had changed hands.
但我猜但泽与奥地利或苏台德地区略有不同，因为后者从未属于德国，而但泽曾是德国的一部分。是的。所以这就像对我们来说，我不知道，伯恩茅斯是个开放城市什么的。你会想，嗯。我猜吧。我的意思是，但泽有，但泽曾经历过艰难时期，当时但泽是波兰的。所以它曾易手。
So maybe Berwick. Yeah, maybe Berwick is a good example. Danzig, don't forget, the population is 90% German. And most ordinary Germans would absolutely say Danzig ought to be part of Germany. It's bonkers that it's a free city. They don't like the Poles. They are really the one nationality that most Germans are united in regarding as backwards and dirty and all of that kind of thing. And most people, they simply can't conceive that the Western powers would fight for Danzig. After all, they didn't fight for the Sudetenland. Why would they fight
所以也许是伯威克（Berwick）。是的，也许伯威克是个好例子。别忘了，但泽90%的人口是德国人。大多数普通德国人都绝对会说但泽应该属于德国。它是一个自由市这简直太荒谬了。他们不喜欢波兰人。波兰人真的是大多数德国人一致认为落后、肮脏等等的唯一国籍。而且大多数人根本无法想象西方列强会为但泽而战。毕竟，他们没有为苏台德地区而战。他们怎么会为一个
for what is obviously a German city? That's the way they think about it. So while all that's going on, Hitler is planning this diplomatic coup. So if you're Hitler and you look at this, the one thing you fear most is that you would fight Britain and France in the West and Poland and the Soviet Union in the East. Now a deal with the Soviet Union, obviously it would be a massive U-turn because so much of Hitler's ideology is based on anti-Bolshevism. But all this time Ribbentrop has been saying to him, I mean, just think if
显然是德国的城市而战呢？他们就是这么想的。所以，当这一切正在发生时，希特勒正在策划这场外交政变。如果你是希特勒，你看着这一切，你最害怕的一件事就是你在西方与英法作战，同时在东方与波兰和苏联作战。现在，与苏联达成协议，显然将是一个巨大的180度大转弯，因为希特勒的大部分意识形态都是建立在反布尔什维克主义基础上的。但这段时间里里宾特洛普一直对他说：我的意思是，试想一下，如果我们真的与斯大林达成协议，它将解决多少问题。这真的很离谱吗？
we did have a deal with Stalin, it would solve so many problems. Is it really so outlandish? Isn't it a good idea? You know, shouldn't we think about it? And the good news for the Nazis is that from Stalin's point of view as well, the timing is absolutely perfect because Stalin has just had this, the great terror. He has just killed almost a million people in two years, including almost all of the top brass of the Red Army and the people who run all the munitions factories and all of the technical experts and all of these people.
这不是个好主意吗？我们难道不应该考虑一下吗？对纳粹来说好消息是，从斯大林的角度来看，时机也绝对完美，因为斯大林刚刚经历了“大清洗”。他在两年内杀害了近百万人，包括红军几乎所有的最高层将领、所有军工厂的管理人员、所有的技术专家以及所有这些类型的人。
He's killed all these people. The Red Army is in an absolute mess, total shambles. He knows that one day Hitler will attack him because Hitler has been saying that for two decades. He knows he's in no state to resist. So he thinks, well, why not? I mean, why not buy ourselves a little bit more time? Because although he knows as well, of course, that Britain and France, you know, they've
他杀了所有人。红军陷入了一团糟，彻底的混乱中。他知道总有一天希特勒会攻击他，因为希特勒已经这样说了二十年。他知道自己根本没有抵抗的能力。所以他想，好吧，为什么不呢？我的意思是，为什么不为我们自己争取多一点时间呢？因为虽然他也清楚英法两国，你知道，它们
made informal kind of feelers about a deal with Stalin, but he knows that they despise him. And he also thinks they're weak, right? I think it's that that's more important, because obviously, Hitler despises him too. I mean, everyone hates him. Yeah. But it's the perceived weakness of Britain and France, surely. Because Stalin is a strong man. And so he respects, even if he fears other strongmen. The British and French do send a military mission to talk to Stalin. Have you seen this? And it was led by a man called Admiral Sir Reginald Ailmore Ranfurly Plunkett Ernold Earl
曾就与斯大林达成协议进行过非正式的试探，但他知道他们鄙视他。而且他也认为他们很软弱，对吧？我认为这才是更重要的，因为显然希特勒也鄙视他。我的意思是，每个人都讨厌他。是的。但肯定是英法被认为软弱。因为斯大林是个强人。所以他尊重，即使他害怕其他强人。英法确实派出了一个军事代表团去和斯大林谈。你见过这个吗？它由一个叫雷金纳德·艾尔莫·兰福利·普伦克特·厄诺德·厄尔·德拉克（Admiral Sir Reginald Ailmore Ranfurly Plunkett Ernold Earl Drax）的海军上将率领
Drax. It just seems disrespectful of Stalin not to respond to a man with so many names. Yes, a peace mission led by a man with so many names. But this guy is quite a junior guy and the French send, I think, an even more junior person. And Stalin is like, what are these people are not serious? I mean, they're never going to give me a proper deal. Like it would have to answer to their parliaments and all that. This isn't going to go anywhere. And that's another key thing, isn't it? Yeah. That the British and French
对于一个有着这么多名字的人，斯大林不予回应似乎有点不尊重。是的，一个由有着无数名字的人领导的和平代表团。但这家伙是个相当低级别的官员，法国派去的我想要更低级别。斯大林觉得：这些人不是认真的吗？我的意思是，他们永远不会给我一个合适的协议。就像他们必须向议会交代之类的那样。这根本谈不出结果。这也是关键的一点，不是吗？是的。英法
governments do have parliaments and electorates to answer to. Exactly. Whereas neither Hitler nor Stalin have to worry about that. Exactly. And obviously, communists and fascists respectively will be appalled at the idea of cozying up to the enemy, but who cares? They'll just have to lump it. Yeah, exactly. That's the thing.
政府确实有议会和选民需要交代。没错。而无论是希特勒还是斯大林都不用担心这一点。没错。而且显然，共产主义者和法西斯主义者分别会为向敌人献媚的想法感到震惊，但谁在乎呢？他们只能忍着。是的，绝对的。就是这样。
So Stalin that spring started to send out signals to the Germans. He started to make speeches attacking the West. He sacked his long serving foreign minister, Maxim Litvinov, who hated the Nazis and had been trying to work for years for better relations with the West. He replaces him with Vyacheslav Molotov, named after the hammer. Is it like Charles Martel? Yeah, like Charles Martel. Molotov means hammer in Russian. So Molotov is the ultimate kind of Stalin ultra-loyalist, and is not Jewish.
所以斯大林那个春天开始向德国人释放信号。他开始发表攻击西方的演讲。他解除了长期担任外长、痛恨纳粹并多年来一直致力于改善与西方关系的马克西姆·李维诺夫（Maxim Litvinov）的职务。他用维亚切斯拉夫·莫洛托夫（Vyacheslav Molotov）取代了他，这个名字是以锤子命名的。就像查理·马特（Charles Martel）那样？是的，就像查理·马特。莫洛托夫在俄语中是锤子的意思。所以莫洛托夫是终极的斯大林超级忠诚者，而且不是犹太人。
And the Nazis take that as a very promising sign. Ribbentrop loves this idea of a deal because, of course, A, it would stab Britain in the back, which he hates Britain and he can't wait to see what a coup that would be. But also for Ribbentrop, Ribbentrop is the ultimate courtier. He wants to cement his position as Hitler's most effective and most loyal underling, especially vis-a-vis his great enemy, Göring. So Ribbentrop is kind of working very hard on this all through the summer. And on the 5th of August, a Soviet diplomat says to him, you know, Stalin is
纳粹认为这是一个非常吉祥的迹象。里宾特洛普非常喜欢达成协议的想法，因为A，这会在背后捅英国一刀，而他痛恨英国，等不及看到这是一场多么惊人的政变。而且对里宾特洛普来说，里宾特洛普是终极的朝臣。他想巩固自己作为希特勒最有效率、最忠诚的下属的地位，尤其是相对于他的死敌戈林而言。因此，整个夏天里宾特洛普都在为此努力工作。8月5日，一名苏联外交官对他说：你知道，斯大林
actually quite interested in this. You know, this could, this could happen. And then they get this great breakthrough on the night of the 19th of August. So the first of all, the Soviets agree after months of on-off talks, they agree a trade deal with the Nazis. They will sell them raw materials in return for German manufactured goods. And then Hitler and Ribbentrop are at the eagle's nests, overlooking this amazing sort of panorama of the mountains on the German Austrian border. And they get a call. Stalin would like to open talks about a deal, a non-aggression pact.
其实对这个相当感兴趣。你知道，这可能会发生。然后他们在8月19日夜里取得了重大突破。首先，经过几个月的时断时续的会谈，苏联人同意与纳粹达成一项贸易协议。他们将向纳粹出售原材料，以换取德国的制成品。然后希特勒和里宾特洛普在鹰巢，俯瞰德奥边境群山那令人惊叹的全景。他们接到一个电话。斯大林希望就一项协议开启会谈，一项互不侵犯条约。
I mean, we know what they're worth, but more importantly, a deal to divide up Poland between them. And he's, and he's inviting Ribbentrop to Moscow to conclude the deal. Now, Ribbentrop, as you can imagine, is absolutely thrilled by this. Stalin says, I'd like you to come in a week on the 26th of August. And at that, Hitler's face falls a little bit
我的意思是，我们知道这些条约的分量，但更重要的是，一项瓜分波兰的协议。并且他邀请里宾特洛普去莫斯科敲定协议。现在，里宾特洛普可想而知，对此兴奋极了。斯大林说：我希望你在一个星期后的8月26日来。听到这个消息，希特勒的脸稍微沉了下来。
when he hears the news. He says, oh, that's very late. I really need the army to strike Poland, you know, at latest 1st of September, because once it starts raining, that will turn the flat fields of Western Poland into a quagmire and that'll be very bad for our tanks. So really, we would ideally like this deal earlier. And Hitler does something extraordinary. He intervenes personally. He sends a personal message to Stalin via the German Embassy in Moscow.
他说：哦，太晚了。我真的需要军队在最迟9月1日打击波兰，因为一旦开始下雨，那会把波兰西部的平原变成泥潭，这对我们的坦克非常不利。所以实际上，我们理想情况下希望这个协议早点达成。而希特勒做了一件非同寻常的事。他亲自介入了。他通过德国驻莫斯科大使馆向斯大林发送了一则个人讯息。
Please can Ribbentrop come earlier to Moscow. This makes an incredible impression on Stalin. Stalin has always been treated by the West as a complete pariah, as a kind of madman, you know, an animal, loose in the world of civilized human beings. And here is Hitler, who has demonised Stalin for so long, treating him as an equal, treating him with respect, saying, asking very politely, please can my Foreign Minister come a week earlier. So a tribute to the efficacy of good manners. Yes, I guess so, Tom. Because two days later, on the afternoon of the 21st of August, Stalin
请让里宾特洛普早点去莫斯科。这给斯大林留下了极其深刻的印象。斯大林一直被西方视为一个彻头彻尾的流放者、某种疯子，你知道的，一头在文明人类世界中游荡的野兽。而这里是希特勒——长期将斯大林妖魔化的人——将他视为平等的人，以尊重对待他，非常礼貌地请求：请问我的外长能否提前一周来。因此，这证明了良好礼貌的效力。是的，我想是的，汤姆。因为两天后，即8月21日下午，斯大林
sends a telegram back and he says, Oh, that would be lovely. Rubin Trott will be very welcome here in two days time on the 23rd of August. And Hitler inevitably is with Albert Speer at the eagle's nest when he hears architectural chit chat. Yeah, balustrades or something. When he gets the news and Speer wrote an account of this, he said, Hitler stared into space for a moment. He flushed deeply.
回了一封电报，他说：哦，那太好了。里宾特洛普将非常受欢迎，请在两天后的8月23日来这里。希特勒在鹰巢听到这个消息时，不可避免地和阿尔伯特·施佩尔在一起，进行建筑方面的闲聊。是的，栏杆什么的。当他听到这个消息时，施佩尔对此写了一段记述，他说：希特勒凝视着虚空片刻。他满脸通红。
Then he banged on the table so hard that the glass is rattled. And he exclaimed in a voice breaking with excitement, I have them. I have them. And then he called for champagne. And who do you think the them is? That's so I was thinking about that. I think it's Britain and France. I think at this point,
然后他重重地拍了一下桌子，以至于玻璃杯都震动了。他用一种因兴奋而破音的声音大声喊道：我抓住他们了。我抓住他们了。然后他叫来了香槟。你认为“他们”指的是谁？我在想这个。我猜那是英法。我想在这一刻，
or the polls as well, possibly the polls as well, of course, but I think he is maddened with hatred now of of the West Hitler, because they he feels they cheated him of his war, and then they gave the polls that guarantee, you know, he's, he's a bitter, he's a he's a bad man out of Hitler, Tom, what can I say? Anyway, the news breaks. They announced the news in Berlin just a couple of hours later, so just before midnight. They don't keep it secret. No, that's this is an interesting thing. Yeah. Until I'd read up on this, this was a revelation to me.
或者也可能是波兰人，当然波兰人也可能，但我认为希特勒现在对西方的恨已经达到疯狂的地步，因为他觉得他们骗走了他的战争，然后他们给了波兰人那种保证。你知道，他是一个充满怨恨、脾气糟糕的希特勒，汤姆，我能说什么呢？无论如何，消息传开了。他们在柏林刚刚几个小时后就宣布了这个消息，也就是午夜前不久。他们没有保密。不，这是一个有趣的事。直到我读到相关资料时，这对我来说是个启示。
I'd always thought it was done kind of back channels and know that the reaction to the Nazi Soviet Pact actually comes before the pact is formally signed. So they announced the news Ribbentrop will be flying to Moscow to conclude a deal with Stalin. And now some old, you know, long standing Nazis are appalled. And actually, there are stories of people throwing down their badges outside party headquarters in Munich, Munich, where the Nazi party began, people who would be very, very anti-Bolshevik and would have been for 20 years. They were like, what? The Bolsheviks are our greatest enemies and they're throwing their badges away. But lots of Germans actually think, oh, brilliant. Now we won't have a war with Russia. And that's
我一直以为这是通过某种内部渠道进行的，并且知道对纳粹-苏联互不侵犯条约的反应实际上发生在该条约正式签署之前。所以他们宣布了消息：里宾特洛普将飞往莫斯科与斯大林敲定协议。现在一些老资历的纳粹分子感到震惊。实际上，有报道称人们在慕尼黑——纳粹党发源的地方——的党部外面扔掉党徽，那些曾是非常坚定的反布尔什维克、并且坚持了20年的人。他们当时想：什么？布尔什维克是我们最大的敌人，而他们却把党徽扔掉了。但许多德国人实际上想：太棒了。现在我们不会与俄国打仗了，这
such a relief. Isn't that wonderful? You know, great news because of course they don't want war. The communists, of course, are kind of, they're more, I guess, kind of ideologically principled on this kind of thing, I guess. I think, I think bewildered is the, yeah, bewildered and confused. If you're a Stalinist, of course, you just say, well, Stalin is the great genius. But there are definitely a lot of communists who are proper Marxists who are appalled by this and who are really troubled by it. But then lots of people make up excuses.
真是松了一口气。难道不是很棒吗？你知道，这真是个好消息，因为他们当然不想打仗。当然，共产主义者在这类事情上在意识形态上可能更有原则性一些。我想，我想“迷惑”是，是的，感到迷惑和困惑。如果你是个斯大林主义者，你当然会说：好吧，斯大林是个伟大的天才。但确实有很多真正的马克思主义共产党人对此外感到震惊，并为此深感困扰。不过接着很多人都在找借口。
They say, well, Stalin had no choice. He was abandoned by the West, all of that kind of thing. So the next day, the 22nd, Hitler convenes a big summit at the, at the Berghof at the Eagle's Nest. He gets 50 senior officers and Ribbentrop. Ribbentrop has packed his bags and is poised to fly. And Hitler says, this is a really important meeting. I don't want anyone to take any notes. It is absolutely top secret. But because it's so important, some of them write down their recollections afterwards.
他们说：好吧，斯大林别无选择。他被西方抛弃了，诸如此类的事情。所以第二天，即22日，希特勒在贝希特斯加登（Berghof）的鹰巢召集了一场盛大的峰会。他找了50名高级军官和里宾特洛普。里宾特洛普已经收拾好行李，随时准备起飞。希特勒说：这是一次非常重要的会议。我不希望任何人做任何笔记。这是绝对最高机密。但因为事关重大，其中一些人后来写下了他们的回忆。
So we kind of know what Hitler said. And even by his own standards, it's an extraordinary performance. He says, I'd always planned for a European war. And I'd always thought we'd fight West and then East, but I've changed my mind. It's because of the economic situation, because the wheels are about to come off our economy. And he says to them, the reason we're doing this now is because of me, because I'm actually such an extraordinary person. Everything depends on me because of my political talents, there will never again in the future be a man with more authority than I have. I mean, imagine listening to this from your boss. I could be eliminated at any time by a criminal or a lunatic. No one knows
所以我们大体上知道希特勒说了什么。即使按他自己的标准来看，这也是一场非同寻常的表演。他说：我一直计划发动一场欧洲战争。我一直认为我们会先打西方然后打东方，但我改变主意了。这是因为经济形势，因为我们的经济车轮快要脱落了。他对手下说：我们现在这样做的原因是因为我，因为我实际上是一个如此非凡的人。一切都取决于我，因为我的政治才华，未来绝不会再有一个人拥有比我更高的权威。我的意思是，想象一下从你的老板那里听到这话。我随时可能被一个罪犯或疯子干掉。没有人知道
how much longer I shall live. Therefore, we'll have to have the war now because I mean, I could be dead in a year. Who knows. You'd be worried, I guess, if you were kind of human resources manager, if you heard the boss of your organization talking like that. You would. Now this is when he comes out with his line about Britain and France being little worms. He says, I saw them in Munich. They won't fight. Yeah.
我还能活多久。因此，我们现在必须打仗，因为我的意思是，我可能一年内就会死。谁知道呢。如果你是人力资源经理，听到你的组织的老板说那样的话，你大概会担心的。确实会。这就是他爆出关于英法是微不足道的虫豸的那番言论的时候。他说：我在慕尼黑见过他们。他们不会打仗。是的。
So it's that personal contact again, isn't it? Yeah. I've looked into their eyes and I've seen that they wimps. Yeah, exactly. And then as for the deal with the Soviet Union, he says, yeah, I mean, it's a, so it's an unusual departure for a fascist. However, he says, I know that Stalin is a very sick man. I mean, talk about projection.
所以又是那种个人接触，不是吗？是的。我看着他们的眼睛，看出他们都是懦夫。是的，exactly。至于与苏联的协议，他说：是的，我的意思是，这对法西斯主义者来说是一个不寻常的背离。然而，他说，我知道斯大林是一个非常有病的人。真是说曹操曹操到，谈谈心理投射。
Stalin, he says, is a very sick man. After Stalin's death, we'll rip up the deal and we will break the Soviet Union and then there will begin the dawn of the German rule of the earth. Imagine listening to that with a straight face. I mean, obviously these guys do listen to a straight face. Now after lunch, he outlines the plans for how they're going to fight the war in Poland. We'll talk about that next week in Monday's episode about the war in Poland itself. So we'll just leave the speech at that point. Because this is the point when Ribbentrop leaves. Ribbentrop excuses himself after lunch. He flies to Berlin. Then he gets on Hitler's, he changes
斯大林，他说，是一个病得很重的人。斯大林死后，我们要撕毁协议，我们要瓦解苏联，然后德国统治世界的黎明就会到来。想象一下一本正经地听这些话。我的意思是，这些人显然确实是一本正经地在听。午饭后，他概述了他们将如何在波兰打这场仗的计划。我们将在下周一关于波兰战役本身的节目中讨论这个问题。所以我们就把演讲留在那个节点。因为这是里宾特洛普离开的时刻。里宾特洛普在午饭后告辞。他飞往柏林。然后他坐上了希特勒的，他换乘了
planes to Hitler's private Condor plane and he flies to East Prussia. He spends the evening in East Prussia and he's nervously going over his notes for the meeting with Molotov the next day. And then on the early morning of the 23rd, Ribbentrop flies on to Moscow. What an extraordinary moment this is. I mean, imagine what's going through his mind. And he takes with him, by the way, Hitler's personal photographer Heinrich Hoffman, who's a great source on this. And we'll be talking about some of the comic activities with photographs later on. Cigars, isn't it? Cigars and photographs and drinking. So Ribbentrop finally lands in Moscow and he is met by sort
希特勒的私人康多尔专机，飞往东普鲁士。他在东普鲁士度过了傍晚，紧张地翻阅着第二天与莫洛托夫会谈的笔记。然后在23日清晨，里宾特洛普飞往莫斯科。这是一个多么非同寻常的时刻。我的意思是，想象一下他脑子里在想什么。顺便说一句，他还随身带了希特勒的私人摄影师海因里希·霍夫曼，他是一个关于这段历史的重要消息来源。我们稍后会讨论一些与照片有关的滑稽活动。雪茄，对吧？雪茄、照片和饮酒。所以里宾特洛普终于在莫斯科降落了，他迎面看到的是一些
of grim faced men with cars straight away and he is driven directly to the Kremlin. The seat of communism on earth, I mean what an incredible moment this is. And he's escorted into this long sort of gilded marble hall with chandeliers and whatnot. And waiting at the end, there's Molotov, but to his surprise, there's also another man, a small man with very familiar features. A pop mark face. Because you have a mustache. And a gigantic mustache.
面容冷峻的人和汽车，他被直接驱车送往克里姆林宫。地球上共产主义的权力中心，我的意思是，这是一个多么令人难以置信的时刻。他被护送进一个长长的、镀金的大理石大厅，里面有枝形吊灯之类的东西。在尽头等待的是莫洛托夫，但让他惊讶的是，还有另一个人，一个身材矮小、特征非常熟悉的人。一张麻脸。因为你留着小胡子。还有一撮巨大的小胡子。
And it is of course, Stalin. Now Ribbentrop didn't know that Stalin was going to be there to meet him, so he's a bit taken aback. And Ribbentrop comes out with his sort of polished diplomatic, you know, lovely to be there to meet him, so he's a bit taken aback. Ribbentrop comes out with his sort of polished diplomatic, you know, lovely to be building a new relationship. We're looking forward to this moment for years. And Stalin is very relaxed and jovial. And Stalin says, we've poured buckets of filth, he uses a much more earthy word than filth, over each other for years. He says, but there's no reason we can't bury the hatchet now. Come on, let's bury the hatchet. And Ribbentrop kicks off
当然，他就是斯大林。里宾特洛普事先并不知道斯大林会亲自来见他，所以他有点大吃一惊。里宾特洛普摆出了那种经过打磨的外交辞令，你知道的，很高兴能来到这里与他见面，所以他有点大吃一惊。里宾特洛普摆出了那种经过打磨的外交辞令，你知道的，很高兴能建立一种新关系。我们多年来一直期盼着这一刻。斯大林非常放松且诙谐。斯大林说，我们多年来互相泼过成吨的污秽——他用了一个比污秽更粗俗的词。他说，但我们现在没有理由不能既往不咎。来吧，让我们既往不咎吧。里宾特洛普抛出了
with a very, very Hitler idea. Let us stun the world with a non-aggression pact to last a hundred years. That's very Dr. Evil. That's very Dr. Evil. And Stalin kind of laughs. And he says, if we say this pact will last for a hundred years, people will laugh at us for not being serious. I suggest 10 years. Ten years is more reasonable. There's the difference between Hitler and Stalin, right? But both of them must equally know it's not going to last. Of course they do.
一个非常非常希特勒式的想法。让我们用一个持续一百年的互不侵犯条约来震惊世界吧。这非常像邪恶博士。这非常像邪恶博士。斯大林笑了笑。他说，如果我们说这个条约将持续一百年，人们会笑话我们不够严肃。我建议10年。十年更合理。这就是希特勒和斯大林的区别，对吧？但他们两个人都同样清楚这不会持久。他们当然清楚。
Even 10 years. Of course they do. That's the amazing thing. Shadow boxing. Absolutely it is. So the pact is one thing, but of course the really important thing is the secret protocol to divide up Europe between them. And Ribbentrop says, here's Hitler's offer.
甚至是10年。他们当然清楚。这就是神奇的地方。影子拳击。绝对是的。所以条约是一回事，但真正重要的当然是瓜分欧洲的秘密议定书。里宾特洛普说，这是希特勒的提议。
You can have Finland, you can have Estonia, you can have most of Latvia, you can have Eastern Poland up to the river Vistula and the San, and you can have the Romanian region of Bessarabia, which is modern day Moldova, which of course they do get. And Stalin says, that's all great, but I would also like the coast of Latvia. And that's a bit of a stumbling block. And Ribbentrop says, I'll have to ring Hitler. I can't agree to that. I'll have to ring Hitler. Now Hitler is at the eagle's nest. And it's an extraordinary scene actually.
你可以拥有芬兰，你可以拥有爱沙尼亚，你可以拥有大部分拉脱维亚，你可以拥有直到维斯瓦河和桑河的波兰东部，你还可以拥有罗马尼亚的比萨拉比亚地区，也就是现在的摩尔多瓦，他们当然也确实得到了这些。斯大林说，这都很好，但我也想要拉脱维亚海岸。这有点像个绊脚石。里宾特洛普说，我得给希特勒打电话。我不能同意这一点。我得给希特勒打电话。现在希特勒在鹰巢。这其实是一个非同寻常的场景。
He's pacing up and down very nervously on the terrace. He's very tense. His adjutant was with him, Nicholas von Belloff. And he described, he said, it was a beautiful evening, an August evening in the mountains, and the sun was setting. Von Bellof said, as we strolled up and down, the eerie turquoise-coloured sky to the north turned first violet and then blood red. At first we thought there must be a serious fire behind the Untesberg, the mountain, but
他在露台上非常紧张地踱来踱去。他非常紧张。他的副官尼古劳斯·冯·贝洛夫和他在一起。他描述说，那是一个美丽的傍晚，山上的八月傍晚，夕阳西下。冯·贝洛夫说，当我们来回漫步时，北面诡异的青绿色天空先是变成紫色，然后变成血红色。起初我们以为翁特斯堡山后面一定发生了严重的大火，但
then the glow covered the whole northern sky in the manner of the northern lights. I was very moved and I told Hitler that it had organ a bloody war. That's nice. That's moving, moving thing to say. And Hitler replied that if it must be so, then the sooner the better. For the more time went by, the bloodier it would be. And at that point the phone rings and everybody's like, oh my God, the phone's ringing. It's the news from Moscow. And Hitler picks up the phone and he just listens in silence.
随后红光像北极光一样笼罩了整个北部天空。我很受触动，我告诉希特勒，这预示着一场血腥的战争。这很好。这是一个感人的、感人的说法。希特勒回答说，如果非如此不可，那就越快越好。因为时间过得越久，就会越血腥。就在这时，电话铃响了，所有人都想，天哪，电话响了。那是来自莫斯科的消息。希特勒拿起电话，只是静静地听着。
He doesn't say anything. And then he puts the phone down and he still says nothing. And then he says, bring me a map. So a map of the people states and someone brings him this map and Hitler stares at it. And then half an hour later he's like, okay, and he rings back and he says, yes, agreed. Now back in Moscow, Ribbentrop puts down the phone and he says it's on. So they finalize the details at midnight.
他什么也没说。然后他放下电话，依然什么也没说。接着他说，给我拿张地图。于是有人拿来了一张各州地图，希特勒盯着它看。半小时后，他好像说，好吧，他回了电话说，是的，同意。现在回到莫斯科，里宾特洛普放下电话说，成了。于是他们在午夜敲定了细节。
Stalin's servants bring in caviar and vodka and Crimean sparkling wine. So Ribbentrop would have enjoyed that. He was a sparkler of sparkling wine. That's true. Maybe he could have a... Yeah. Maybe they did a little tasting. Put me in touch with your supplier. And they light up a load of cigarettes and they start making toasts.
斯大林的仆人们端来了鱼子酱、伏特加和克里米亚起泡酒。所以里宾特洛普一定会喜欢这些。他是个起泡酒迷。确实如此。也许他可以……是的。也许他们小酌品尝了一下。让我联系一下你的供应商。他们点上一堆香烟，开始祝酒。
Stalin incredibly makes this toast. He says, I know how much the German nation loves its Fuhrer. I should like to drink to his health. And he leaves. He keeps that quiet in 1943. He does indeed. Yes, he did. He didn't talk often about that toast.
斯大林令人难以置信地发表了这番祝酒词。他说，我知道德国人民多么热爱他们的元首。我愿为他的健康干杯。然后他离开了。他在1943年对这件事守口如瓶。他确实如此。是的，他确实做到了。他以后很少谈起那次祝酒。
Now the documents are ready. They've been finalized and they're prepared to sign. At this point, Hoffman, the photographer comes in and he sets up this huge tripod and his camera and everything. And Stalin says, hold on, hold on. You can't take photos like this. Like we have to clear all the glasses away, all the caviar, because otherwise people will say they signed this pact when they were absolutely wasted. And that's really bad publicity. So they clear the stuff away and then Hoffman takes the photos. And these are the photos that you see if you Google it. So you see Molotov and Ribbentrop,
现在文件准备好了。它们已经定稿，准备签署。就在这时，摄影师霍夫曼走了进来，架起了这个巨大的三脚架、他的相机和所有设备。斯大林说，等等，等等。你们不能这样拍照。我们必须把所有的酒杯、所有的鱼子酱都清理掉，否则人们会说他们是在酩酊大醉的时候签署了这个条约。这真是极坏的公关。于是他们把东西清理干净，然后霍夫曼拍了照片。这些就是如果你用谷歌搜索就会看到的照片。所以你会看到莫洛托夫和里宾特洛普，
very smart suited actually, given the abuseotov and Ribbentrop very smart suited actually, given the abuse we've given Ribbentrop about his suits. He's signed, they're signing and Stalin is in the background beaming looking very jolly because he's tanked up on vodka and sparkling wine in his kind of beige tunic. Mustache bristling. And then Ribbentrop rings Hitler again. Hitler inevitably has been watching a film with gobbles, but he's not really been enjoying it because he's too nervous. He wants to find out how it's going.
其实穿着非常讲究，考虑到我们之前对里宾特洛普西装的吐槽。他在签署，他们在签署，而斯大林穿着他那件米色束腰外衣，在背景中笑容满面、神情愉快，因为他喝了伏特加和起泡酒，正处于微醺状态。小胡子根根竖起。然后里宾特洛普又给希特勒打电话。希特勒不可避免地一直在和戈培尔看电影，但他其实并没有真正享受，因为他太紧张了。他想知道进展如何。
And Ribbentrop says, brilliant. It has been a complete success. We have everything we wanted. And Hitler says, congratulations. And then Hitler says that will hit them like a bombshell. Well, when we get bombshells in the rest of history, we generally like to take a break. So I think that is what we will do.
里宾特洛普说，太棒了。这是一次彻底的成功。我们得到了我们想要的一切。希特勒说，祝贺。然后希特勒说，这会对他们产生重磅炸弹般的影响。好吧，当我们在历史余音中遇到重磅炸弹时，我们通常喜欢休息一下。所以我想这就是我们要做的。
Hello, welcome back to the rest of history. And Dominic, a bombshell has just exploded in the form of the Molotov-Ribbentrop Pact. It has. Hitler and Stalin have divided up Eastern Europe between them. And how does this all go down? Well, Ribbentrop flies back to Berlin to a hero's reception, not surprisingly. Hitler hails him, says, you know, well done, mate, brilliant. You are second Bismarck. And of course to Ribbentrop, that is music to his ears. Ribbentrop and Hitler now are absolutely convinced this is guaranteed them a free hand against
你好，欢迎回到历史余音。多米尼克，《苏德互不侵犯条约》的重磅炸弹刚刚爆炸了。确实如此。希特勒和斯大林瓜分了东欧。这一切是如何发生的呢？好吧，里宾特洛普飞回柏林，不出所料受到了英雄般的欢迎。希特勒盛赞他，说，你知道的，干得好，伙计，太棒了。你是第二个俾斯麦。当然，对于里宾特洛普来说，这犹如天籁之音。里宾特洛普和希特勒现在绝对确信，这保证了他们在苏联出局后对波兰拥有绝对自由的手腕。
Poland with the Soviet Union out. There is no way Britain and France will fight. They're convinced of this. Now I mentioned the photographer Heinrich Hoffmann. He has come back to and he's been developing his photographs of the signing which Stalin had said clear the glasses away and he goes into the Reich Chancellery to show them to Hitler. Hitler is obsessed with Stalin. He is absolutely obsessed. He's bombarded. He's his only peer, isn't he?
他们坚信英国和法国不会参战。我刚才提到了摄影师海因里希·霍夫曼。他回到了这里，一直在冲洗签约的照片，斯大林曾说过要把酒杯清理掉的那次签约。他走进帝国总理府展示给希特勒看。希特勒对斯大林着迷已久。他绝对着迷了。他被轰炸了。他是他唯一的同辈人，不是吗？
Yes, I think so. Hitler had said, there are only three great men in the world. They are me, Stalin and Mussolini. And Mussolini is definitely third. So Stalin is the other great man. And he's just fascinated with Stalin. And he says to Hoffman, does he order people? Does he order them? Or does he cloak his orders in the guise of wishes? What about his health? Does he really smoke so much? How does he shake hands? What's his handshake like? And then it's just a shame they never met, isn't it? Oh, they'd have gone on so well. A lot of the Nazis, we know this from Ted Heath.
是的，我想是的。希特勒曾说过，世界上只有三个伟人。他们是我、斯大林和墨索里尼。墨索里尼绝对是第三。所以斯大林是另一个伟人。他简直对斯大林着迷。他问霍夫曼，他会对人发号施令吗？他下达命令吗？还是把命令伪装成愿望？他的健康状况如何？他真的抽那么多烟吗？他怎么握手？他的握手是什么样的？然后遗憾的是他们从未见过面，不是吗？哦，他们会很合得来的。我们从特德·希思那里得知，很多纳粹分子都是这样的。
Did you know this? Ted Heath went to a Nuremberg rally, the future British prime minister, when he was on a kind of gap year in Germany. Yeah. In 1938. Yeah. And he said he met Himmler and Goering and all that. He said they had terrible handshakes by and large, very limp drooping handshakes.
你知道这个吗？特德·希思在德国进行间隔年旅行时，曾去参加过纽伦堡集会，这位未来的英国首相。是的。在1938年。是的。他说他遇到了希姆莱、戈林之流。他说他们大体上握手手劲很差，是非常软弱无力的握手。
And I would imagine Hitler had a poor handshake. Stalin, I don't know. I think he'd have a crunching handshake. Stalin's a bear hug kind of man, isn't he? Yeah. The thing that Hitler was really fixated on, have you seen this? Stalin's earlobes. Yes, because that's a sign of Jewishness, isn't it? He says, are they ingrown and Jewish or are they separate and Aryan? And the photographer Hoffman says they're separate and Hitler apparently
我想希特勒的握手也很差。斯大林，我不知道。我想他会有一个很有力的握手。斯大林是个喜欢熊抱的人，对吧？是的。希特勒真正着迷的是——你注意到这个了吗？斯大林的耳垂。是的，因为那是犹太血统的标志，不是吗？他说，它们是内陷且犹太式的，还是分离且雅利安式的？摄影师霍夫曼说它们是分离的，希特勒显然
is delighted by that. He says, Oh, that's brilliant. I'm so pleased. I'm glad that Stalin's got Aryan earlobes. And then they get out the photographs and Hitler's face falls to the floor. What? He says, Oh, what a pity. There's not a single one of these photographs we can use. And Hoffman who's, you know, considers himself quite a good photographer is quite, you know, displeased by this. Why? And Hitler says, well, in every single photograph, Stalin is smoking. And he says the German people would take offense at this. Because Hitler's very anti-smoking, isn't he? Because you were saying in the previous
对此感到高兴。他说，哦，太棒了。我太高兴了。我很高兴斯大林有雅利安人的耳垂。然后他们拿出照片，希特勒的脸一下子沉了下来。什么？他说，哦，太遗憾了。这些照片里没有一张是我们可以使用的。而霍夫曼（你知道的）认为自己是个挺不错的摄影师，对此相当……不悦。为什么？希特勒说，嗯，在每一张照片里，斯大林都在抽烟。他说德国人民会对这一点感到冒犯。因为希特勒非常反感吸烟，不是吗？因为你在上一集中说过
episode how he spent his time wanting to ban them. Yeah, exactly. Hitler wants to reduce nicotine and cigarettes. He's a health and safety Nazi. He's a nanny state Nazi. What can I say? Hitler says, the signing of a pact is a solemn act. Which one does not approach with a cigarette dangling from one's lips? Such a photograph smacks of levity. See if you can paint out the cigarettes. And so the photographs to release to the press by Hoffman have been doctored and Stalin's cigarettes have all been taken out. It's so Orwellian, isn't it? First they came for the cigarettes. That's true. Yeah. Then yes. So Stalin's reaction is fair to say, it's a little bit less eccentric.
他是怎么花时间想要禁烟的。是的，完全正确。希特勒想要减少尼古丁和香烟。他是个健康安全纳粹。他是个保姆国家纳粹。我能说什么呢？希特勒说，签署条约是一个庄严的仪式。人们不会叼着一根香烟走近它。这样的照片带有轻浮的意味。看看能不能把香烟P掉。所以霍夫曼发布给媒体的照片经过了修改，斯大林手里的烟全被去掉了。这太奥威尔了，不是吗？他们首先冲着香烟来。确实如此。是的。然后，是的。所以斯大林的反应可以说，稍微没那么古怪。
So Stalin met his entourage the next day and his underlings had gone out and shot a little duck. He loved eating duck. So they're eating all this duck and Stalin's in brilliant form. He's never been happier. And he says, he's a smarter man than Hitler, frankly. He says, of course it's all a game to see who can fool whom. I know what Hitler's up to. He thinks he's outsmarted me, but it's actually me who has tricked him.
所以斯大林第二天会见了随从，他的手下出去打了一只小野鸭。他很喜欢吃鸭肉。所以他们吃着这些鸭子，斯大林状态极佳。他从未如此快乐过。他说，坦率地说，他比希特勒更聪明。他说，这当然是一场看谁能愚弄谁的游戏。我知道希特勒在搞什么鬼。他以为自己智胜了我，但实际上是我戏弄了他话虽如此……
Although having said that... Is that true? Hitler's the one who launches a surprise attack. Yeah, but who's got the last laugh, Tom? True. I mean, yeah. Anyway, they're both bad men, let's be frank about it. Now in the rest of the world, the reaction, of course, is total shock.
这是真的吗？希特勒才是发动突然袭击的那个人。是的，但谁笑到最后了，汤姆？倒也是。我的意思是，是的。不管怎样，坦白说，他们都是坏人。现在在世界其他地方，反应当然是极度震惊。
Among the communists in British newspapers and French newspapers and so on, Neville Chamberlain is a broken man because of this. Joseph Kennedy, the American ambassador, said he looks like a broken man. He said he could think of nothing further to say or do. He felt that all his work had come to naught. I can't fly again because that was good only once. In other words, Chamberlain recognizes there's no possibility now for any more appeasement. The whole constellation has changed. However, Britain will not change its approach. So this is one thing that Hitler really misjudged. Hitler was convinced that this marked the end of the British and French guarantee
在英国报纸和法国报纸等处的共产党人中，内维尔·伯恩令因此成了一个心碎之人。美国大使约瑟夫·凯尼尔说他看起来像个心碎的人。他说他想不出还能说什么或做什么。他觉得自己所有的努力都付诸东流了。我不能再飞了，因为那招只管用一次。换句话说，张伯伦认识到，现在没有任何绥靖的可能了。整个星座已经变了。然而，英国不会改变其方针。所以这是希特勒真正误判的一点。希特勒深信，这标志着英法对波兰保证的终结，他们绝无可能参战。但实际上在8月22日，即条约签署的消息传到伦敦的那天，英国内阁重申了对波兰的承诺。他们决定派驻柏林大使内维尔·亨德森带着一封信去鹰巢见希特勒，信中说，别搞错了，我们不会改变，我们依然完全致力于保卫波兰。希特勒对此作何反应？
to Poland that there's no way they would fight. But actually the 22nd of August, the day that the news of the signing of the pact reached London, the British cabinet reaffirmed its commitment to Poland. And they decided to send the ambassador in Berlin, Neville Henderson, to the eagle's nest with a letter to Hitler to say, don't get this wrong, we are not going to change, we are still completely committed to Poland. And how does this go down with Hitler? Poorly, I think it's fair to say. So we talked about Henderson last time. He loves a carnation. He's an old Atonian. He's got a gigantic moustache. She's very elegant.
可以说反应很差。所以我们上次谈到了亨德森。他喜欢康乃馨。他是老伊顿生。他留着巨大的胡子。他非常优雅。
Family linked to Alice in Wonderland. Exactly. So Henderson turns up at the eagle's nest and Hitler just starts ranting and raving about it. He can't believe that the British are doing this. Hitler says, you know, you've, you've, we've wanted to be friends with you. You clearly hate us. We will fight you to the last man. And Henderson is very upset by this because he has spent his career trying to get in with the Nazis. He sees that as his task.
家族与《爱丽丝梦游仙境》有关。没错。于是亨德森出现在鹰巢，希特勒开始对此大发雷霆。他不敢相信英国人会这么做。希特勒说，你知道的，你们，我们一直想和你们做朋友。你们显然恨我们。我们要和你们战斗到最后一个人。亨德森对此感到非常难过，因为他职业生涯的大部分时间都在试图巴结纳粹。他认为这是他的任务。
Well, he's a great man for thinking that there are moderates, aren't there? Yes. So there are extreme Nazis and there are moderate Nazis. Yeah. And I think, I think it's fair to say he's probably not right about that. He's not right at all. He's a brilliant lesson in self delusion. And Henderson is really upset by Hitler's reaction. He basically storms out in the verge of tears or verge of a massive outburst of rage or something. I don't think someone who went to Eton in the
好吧，他很擅长认为有温和派存在，对吧？是的。所以有极端纳粹，也有温和派纳粹。是的。我想，我想坦率地说，他在这件事上可能并不对。他完全不对。这是自我妄想的一个绝佳教训。亨德森对希特勒的反应感到非常沮丧。他基本上是愤怒地冲了出去，濒临哭泣的边缘，或者濒临狂怒爆发的边缘什么的。我不认为一个在20世纪上半叶上过伊顿公学的人会哭鼻子。你真的这么认为吗？你真的认为一个在20世纪上半叶上过伊顿公学的人不会哭鼻子吗？你真不这么认为？你觉得罗伊·斯图尔特不会在如此相似的外表下崩溃吗？罗伊·斯图尔特是后来的伊顿生。好吧。但早期的那些。你觉得他们不会？不，我的意思是，去伊顿公学的全部意义就在于，如果你表现出一丝一毫的情感，你就会挨打。
first half of the 20th century would blub. You don't think so? You don't think someone who went to Eaton in the first half of the 20th century would blub. You don't think so? You don't think Roy Stewart would break down in such a similar surface? Roy Stewart's a later Atonian. Okay. But the early ones. You don't think they would? No, I mean, that's the whole point of going to Eaton is you get beaten if you show a kind of single trace of emotion.
好吧。嗯，我认为亨德森在这个时候非常情绪化，因为他所有的工作都付诸东流了。当他走出去时，你知道希特勒做了什么吗？他 literalmente 狠狠地拍了一下大腿。这是希特勒的一大标志性动作。他很喜欢拍大腿。他确实咯咯笑了。他说，张伯伦挺不过这次讨论的。他的内阁今晚就会倒台。这真的感觉像是一种棋盘游戏，不是吗？有点像外交游戏什么的。确实如此。但也正是其中一个人现在完全失去了对现实的感知，因为张伯伦的内阁绝不可能分崩离析。我的意思是，希特勒完全产生幻觉了。所以我想在这个时候，希特勒已经完全失去了解读英国和法国局势的能力。我的意思是，他彻底糊涂了，因为接下来的几天过去了，他收到了所有来自伦敦的报告，说英国实际上正在为战争做准备。他们做好了海岸防御准备，征用了商船，让防空警报处于待命状态。在法国，将近一百万男丁被征召入伍。希特勒无法理解这一点。什么？为什么他们要死守对波兰的疯狂承诺？
All right. Well, Henderson, I think, is very emotional at this point because all his work has come to nothing. And when he goes out, do you know what Hitler does? He literally slaps his thigh. This was Hitler's great thing. He loves to slap his thigh. He does chortle. He says, Chamberlain won't survive this discussion. His cabinet will fall this evening. It does really feel like a kind of board game, doesn't it? Kind of like diplomacy or something. It does. But also in which one person has now completely lost sight of reality because there's no way Chamberlain's cabinet is going to fall apart. I mean, Hitler is completely deluded. So I think at this point, Hitler has just completely lost the ability to read what's
为什么他们不向现实妥协？所以他说，好吧，我显然得改变战术了。所以在星期五，也就是8月25日，他已经搬回了柏林，他说，把亨德森找回来。于是亨德森回到帝国总理府，希特勒说，听着，我改变主意了。我会给英国一个非常慷慨的提议。如果你让我解决这个波兰问题，我保证这就是全部了。我将保证大英帝国的完整。实际上，只要你们允许我们收回一些1914年以前的殖民地，我甚至可以把德军借给你们
going on in Britain and France. I mean, he's all over the shop because the next couple of days go by and he gets all these reports from London, the British are actually preparing for war. They've made coastal defence preparations, they have requisitioned merchant ships, they put their air raid on standby. In France, almost a million men have been called up to the colours. Hitler can't get his head around this. What? Why are they sticking by the mad pledge to Poland?
来保卫大英帝国。所以，拜托，这是一笔划算的交易。我们可以成为朋友。他说，嗯，你知道吗，这是一笔多么划算的交易啊。实际上，我认为你应该坐我的私人飞机去伦敦，亲自把它提供给张伯伦。然后他说，我的意思是，这太无耻了。他对亨德森说，问题是，实际上我，我其实讨厌战争。我不是，我不是一个战争贩子，我不是一个战士。我是一个艺术家。当波兰这摊子事解决后，我可能会放弃，然后重回艺术之路，因为那才是我真正热衷的。所以，多米尼克，我的意思是，这一集又一集的全部内容，精彩绝伦，宏大壮丽，
Why haven't they yielded to reality? So he says, well, I'm going to have to change tactics clearly. So on the Friday, which is the 25th of August, he's moved back to Berlin and he says, get Henderson back. So Henderson comes back to the Reich Chancellery and it says, look, I've changed my mind. I will make Britain a very generous offer. If you let me solve this Polish problem, I promise that will be it. And I will guarantee the integrity of the British Empire. And actually, I'll even lend you German forces
你为自己赢得了无上的荣耀，但此时此刻你让自己蒙羞了。才没有。你在笔记里写道，他，希特勒，就是约翰·列农。是的。只是个艺术家。你打算拍着大腿咯咯笑吗？几乎可以肯定。但等录音结束后，我想，私下里，只要想象一下，汤姆，想象一下没有宗教。
to defend the British Empire as long as you will let us have some of our pre 1914 colonies back. So come on, that's a brilliant deal. We can be friends. And he says, um, do you know what, it's such a good deal. Actually, I think you should take my private plane and go to London and offer it to Chamberlain personally. And then he says, I mean, this is shameless. He says to Henderson, the thing is, I actually, I actually hate war. I don't, I'm not a war, I'm not a warrior. I'm an artist. When this Polish business is settled, I'll probably give up and just go back to art because that's what I'm really all about. So Dominic, I mean, this whole thing on all these episodes, tour de force, magnificent,
你知道的，想象没有国家。这并不难做到。希特勒后来就是这么说的。他只是热爱艺术。拜托。所以讽刺的是，当然，当希特勒在大谈特谈艺术时（你知道的，想象这个和那个），他的将军们正准备在第二天一早（即8月26日星期六）发动对波兰的入侵，一切都准备好了。最终的决定被推迟了，因为希特勒还在
you've covered yourself in glory, but at this point you shame yourself. No. You've written in your notes, he, Hitler, is John Lennon. Yeah. Just an artist. Are you going to slap your thigh and chortle? Almost certainly. But once the recording is finished, I think, just privately, just imagine, Tom, imagine there's no religion.
和亨德森谈论他对水彩画的热爱。但终于在那个下午，他下达了命令：我们明天（26日）早上4点30分进去，英国人会被打个措手不及，这将是一个既成事实，他们只能忍气吞声。太棒了。一切就绪，机器运转起来了。将军们准备好了。然后难以置信的是，那天晚上7点30分，他们收到了希特勒的新命令。取消了。不打了。
You know, imagine there's no countries. It's not, it isn't hard to do. That's what Hitler said afterwards. He just loves art. Come on. So the irony is, of course, while Hitler is pontificating about art, you know, imagine this and that and the other. His generals are preparing to launch the invasion of Poland the very next morning, the very next morning, Saturday, the 26th of August, everything is ready. The final decision is delayed because Hitler is still
发生了什么？发生了什么？难以置信的转折。好吧，墨索里尼。墨索里尼再次搅局了。那天下午晚些时候，他给希特勒发了一条消息。你计划的这场战争是……但实际上我一点也不想打这场战争。意大利还没准备好打仗。我们不看好这个。希特勒简直不敢相信。什么？钢铁同盟白结了？他说，墨索里尼背叛了我。意大利人
talking to Henderson about his love of watercolours. But at last, that afternoon, he gives the order will go in tomorrow, the 26th, 430 in the morning, the British will be taken by surprise, it'll be a fate to complete, they'll just have to suck it up. Brilliant. Everything is ready, the wheels are put in motion. The generals are ready. And then unbelievably at 730 that evening, they get a new order from Hitler. It's off. It's cancelled.
的表现就像他们在1914年一样。你永远无法依靠意大利人。所以，我的意思是，希特勒撕毁条约和协定是可以的，但当别人对他这么做时，他一点也不喜欢。是的。另一方面，汤姆，你可以说意大利人在1940年让德国失望了。所以希特勒本该有所预料的。无论如何，现在阻止所有的准备工作已经太晚了。军队大发雷霆。我的意思是，他们确实停止了大部分准备工作，但有些部队还是继续前进了。所以在喀尔巴阡山脉的一个铁路隧道发生了一次进攻，结果在夜间被波兰人击退了。
What's happened? What's happened? Unbelievable twist. Well, Mussolini. Mussolini once again has thrown a spanner in the works. Late that afternoon, he sent Hitler a message. This war you're planning is, but actually I don't fancy this war at all. Italy's not ready for a war. We don't fancy this. Hitler can't believe it. What, the Pact of Steel is for nothing? He says, Mussolini has betrayed me. The Italians are
波兰人原本想下令进行他们自己的全国总动员，但英法两国说，别这么做，别这么做。不要挑衅希特勒。正如我们下次将要发现的——这对波兰人来说真的很糟糕，这太糟糕了，因为这意味着当战争真正开始时，他们根本没有做好充分准备。因此，由于墨索里尼的拖延，时间表某种程度上被冻结了。每个人都还在原地，但战争被推迟了。这给了希特勒最后一次与英国达成协议的机会。现在
behaving just like they did in 1914. You can never rely on the Italians. So, I mean, it's all right for Hitler to rip up pacts and treaties, but when it's done to him, he doesn't like it at all. Yeah. On the other hand, Tom, you could say the Italians had let Germany down in 1940. So Hitler should perhaps have been forewarned. Anyway, it's too late to stop all the preparations. The army are outraged. I mean, they do stop most of the preparations, but some units do go ahead. So there's an attack on a railway tunnel in the Carpathians that is actually beaten back by the Poles overnight.
在这个节点上，他已经放弃了传统外交。（你知道的，和亨德森的那套显然行不通了。）里宾特洛普说，听着，没用了。（你知道的，他们不会让步的，他们现在不会抛弃波兰的。）但戈林还穿着他的白色西装四处晃悠。他挺喜欢达成交易的想法。他有这个哥们儿——不仅是因为这能巩固达成交易的想法。他有这个哥们儿，是个瑞典实业家，名叫伯格·达勒鲁斯，戈林经常用他作为与伦敦之间的中间人。希特勒说，好吧，也许我们可以用这家伙，这个达勒鲁斯。于是他把这个瑞典人派往伦敦，带去了给英国的同盟提议。
The Poles wanted to order general mobilisation of their own, but the British and the French say, don't do it, don't do it. Don't provoke Hitler. And as we will discover next time- That's really terrible for the Pol time, this is terrible for the polls because it means when the war does start, they are not properly ready. So as a result of Mussolini dragging his feet, the timetable is sort of frozen. Everybody is still in place, but the war has been postponed. And that gives Hitler one last chance to find a deal with Britain. Now
所以他还没有放弃那个老想法。而且再次，这非常让人想起第一次世界大战前的局势。确实是的。我刚才就在想那个，关于德皇在最后一刻与英国达成协议的各种尝试。他说，看，达勒鲁斯的提议是德国得到但泽，德国得到波兰走廊，德国得到它在非洲的旧殖民地等等，但它将保证波兰的边界，并且它将与大英帝国达成这一切交易，它将保卫大英帝国。
at this point, he has given up on traditional diplomacy. You know, the stuff with Henderson isn't going to work clearly. Ribbentrop says, look, it's pointless. You know, they're not going to give, they're not going to abandon Poland now. But Göring is still hanging around in his white suit. He kind of likes the idea of a deal. And he has this mate- Not least because it would kind of stiff the idea of a deal. And he has this mate who's a Swedish industrialist called Berger Dalarus, who Goering uses often as a kind of go-between with London. And Hitler says, well, let's maybe use this bloke, this Dalarus. So he sends this Swedish guy off to London with an alliance offer for Britain.
这次的不同之处在于希特勒说，我们要先达成这笔交易，然后再担心波兰的事。对我来说，和你们英国人做朋友太重要了。现在这个提议有很多无谓的折腾，我们其实不需要深入探讨，因为基本上潜在的现实是，希特勒一直在制定入侵计划。他并没有放弃入侵的想法。所以在达勒鲁斯被派往伦敦后，他召集了纳粹高层，
So he still hasn't given up on that old idea. And again, this is quite reminiscent of the build up to the First World War. It is. I was just thinking about that, about the Kaiser's various attempts at the last minute to have a deal with the British. And he says, look, Dalarus' offer is Germany gets Danzig, Germany gets the Polish corridor, Germany gets its old colonies in Africa and stuff, but it will guarantee Poland's borders and it will do all this deal with the British Empire and it will defend the British Empire.
党卫军领导人希姆莱、海德里希、戈培尔，所有这些坏家伙。希特勒此时已经精疲力竭了。他筋疲力尽。他压力巨大。他的声音都在颤抖，他说，好吧，我们在周五，也就是9月1日动手。不会再有延期了。我下定决心了（你知道的，别再瞎折腾了）。这事一定会发生。
The difference this time is Hitler says, we'll have this deal first and then we'll only worry about the Polish business afterwards. It's so important to me to be friends with you in Britain. Now there's a bit a lot of faffing around with this offer that we don't really need to go into because basically the underlying reality is that all the time Hitler is still making plans for the invasion. He has not given up on the invasion idea. So after Dalarou has been sent off to London, he gathers the Nazi top brass,
他说，这会很残酷。但只要我活着，就绝不会有任何——我们绝不会投降。有趣的是，在这一刻，甚至在这个时刻，在战争甚至还没开始之前，他在他的部分脑海中就已经在考虑他自己的死亡和战败的可能性了。事实上，戈林私下对他说过一次，他说，听着，我们其实不需要和英国人打仗。就像我们不需要，我们不需要这样做。
the leaders of the SS, Himmler, Heidrich, Goebbels, all these bad guys. And Hitler at this point is really strung out. He's exhausted. He's massively stressed. His voice is cracking and he says, okay, we're going to do it on Friday, the 1st of September. There'll be no more postponements. I made up my mind, you know, enough faffing around. This is going to happen.
我们不需要拿一切去赌。因为戈林被告知了，不是吗，德国空军缺乏轰炸英国的能力。而且戈林出于显而易见的原因，对希特勒隐瞒了德国空军的真实能力。他对希特勒说，听着，我们没必要这么做。你知道的，你不需要证明什么。希特勒对他说，我这一生，总是把我全部的筹码都压在桌上。
And he says, this is going to be brutal. But for as long as I live, there will never be any, we would never surrender. It's interesting that at this point, even at this point, before it's even started, he's contemplating, at least in part of his mind, his own death and the possibility of defeat. And actually Goering says to him privately at one point, he says, listen, we don't actually need to fight the British. Like we don't, we don't need to do this.
确实如此。他赌了又赌，赌了又赌，赢了又赢，赢了又赢，直到他不再赢——直到他不再赢，完全正确。所以在星期一（28日）的晚上，亨德森再次现身。他喝了半瓶香槟来稳定情绪。香槟，这帮人在见希特勒之前怎么都爱喝起泡酒？他说，看，我们得到了这个瑞典人的最新消息。我们不会和你做交易的。
We don't need to gamble everything. Cause Goering has been told, hasn't he, that the Luftwaffe lacks the capacity to bomb Britain. And Goering has not, I think, been completely honest with Hitler about the Luftwaffe's capabilities for obvious reasons. And he says, he says to Hitler, look, we don't need to do this. You know, you don't need to prove anything. And Hitler says to him all my life, I've always put my entire stake on the table.
但当但泽这摊子事还在拖延时，好吧，我们可以谈谈但泽，但你绝不可能入侵，因为如果你这么做了，我们就会和你战斗。希特勒说，好吧，我考虑一下。于是过了一天，在周二（29日）的晚上，亨德森回来听答复，而此时的柏林一片黑暗。柏林政府下令进行了一次灯火管制演练。帝国总理府外面有数百人在等待，因为他们知道这是和平的最后机会了。
Which is true. He gambled and gambled and gambled and won and won and won until he didn't until he didn't exactly. So the evening of Monday, the 28th, Henderson pitches up again. He's drunk half a bottle of champagne to steady himself. Champagne, what is it with sparkling wine and these people before meeting Hitler? And he says, look, we've got the latest stuff from this Swedish guy. We're not going to do a deal with you.
而希特勒——我的意思是，我本来想说这令人难以置信，但当然这是完全可信的。他决定使出他在巴特戈德斯贝格对张伯伦用过的同一招。他决定彻底改变游戏规则，提高赌注。所以他不再伪装成好先生，而是开始大吵大闹，哦，我受够你们英国人了，你们根本不在乎德国人，你们不在乎我们是不是在被屠杀。他说，哦，这全都是你们的错，你们包围了德国，你们欺骗了我们，你们背叛了我们，诸如此类的话。亨德森，这大概是他外交生涯中第一次，在面对希特勒时，彻底失去了理智。他说，我不会听你或者任何人说这种语言。你怎么敢侮辱英国政府。如果你想要战争，亨德森说，那你们就会得到战争。希特勒说，好吧，很好。我的意思是，波兰人明天应该派个人来把我要的一切都交给我。如果他们不这么做，我就派军队进去。我再也不等了。现在其实，神奇的是，亨德森在这个时候，他走了出去，愤怒得直冒烟，但因为他身处其中，并且一直是个绥靖主义者，他的一部分仍然，你知道的，他的一部分仍然想要达成交易。所以他实际上对伦敦说，是的，也许我们应该让波兰人去谈判。
But while this Danzig thing is dragging on, fine, we can talk about Danzig, but there is no way that you can invade because if you do that, we will fight you. And Hitler says, okay, I'll think about it. So a day goes by then on the evening of Tuesday, the 29th, Henderson comes back for his answer and Berlin now is in darkness. The government in Berlin has ordered a trial blackout. There are hundreds of people waiting outside the Reich Chancellery because they know that this is kind of the last chance for peace.
是的，也许我们不应该彻底放弃。而在伦敦的张伯伦说，绝不，（你知道的）我们不会再被希特勒欺负了。张伯伦此时，我认为，对绥靖政策的耐性确实已经耗尽了。他说，我们在这一点上绝不退让。没有什么好讨论的了。所以舞台真的搭好了。第二天，即30日星期星期三，波兰人开始动员。他们本该早点这么做的。他们在英法的要求下拖延了，以避免激怒德国人。这将付出极为沉重的代价，
And Hitler, I mean, I was going to say unbelievably, but of course it's perfectly credible. He decides to try the same trick that he had done in Bad Goudersberg with Chamberlain. He decides to just completely change the rules of the game and raise the stakes. And so instead of being Mr. Nice, he starts ranting and raving, oh, you're sick of you British, you don't care about Germans, you don't care if we're being slaughtered. And he says, oh, it's all your, you've encircled Germany, you've tricked us, you've betrayed us, all of this kind of thing. Henderson, for the first time, probably in his diplomatic career, really, with Hitler, completely loses his temper. And he says, I won't listen to this language from
我很遗憾地这么说。我可以问你吗，如果他们动员是出于英法会对德国宣战的期望，但更重要的是，期望英法会在西部攻击德国，从而给波兰人一线生机来，来生存下去。你认为如果他们知道英、法实际上会采取行动，而不是只是坐在那里无所事事？在这种情况下，他们可能会进行谈判吗？不，我不这么认为。我认为他们还是会打。我想他们可能仍然会打。我想他们无法想象英法不会干涉。好吧。所以这不是个问题。
you or from anybody. How dare you insult the British government. If you want to war says Henderson, then you will have it. And Hitler says, well, fine. I mean, the polls should come send someone tomorrow to give me everything that I want. And if they don't, I'll send in my army. I'm not waiting any longer. Now actually, amazingly, Henderson at this point, he walked out and he's steaming with rage, but he's still because he's in the Pisa and has always been in a Pisa. he's still partly, you know, part of him still wants a deal. And so he actually says to London, yeah, maybe we should get the polls to negotiate.
是的，但我认为英法发出了稍微有些矛盾的信号。他们派出了一个军事代表团。他们运送了一些相当可怜的物资。英法一直在对他们说，（你知道的）这将是一场漫长的战争。他们一直在暗示，他们的干预可能不会像波兰人所希望的那样具有颠覆性。但我认为，波兰的民族自豪感、波兰的公众舆论，使得任何形式的妥协都变得非常非常困难。所以我们现在到哪一步了？1939年8月31日星期四。那天一早，希特勒对他的将领们说，入侵明天开始。他在中午刚过签署了进攻命令，然后在一个小时后确认了这一消息。那天下午，那天下午早些时候，
Yeah, maybe we shouldn't give up completely. And Chamberlain back in London says, no way, you know, we're not going to be bullied again by Hitler. Chamberlain by this point has, I think, definitely run out of patience with the policy of appeasement. He says, we are not going to yield on this point. There is nothing more to discuss. So the stage really is set now. The next day, Wednesday the 30th, the polls begin to mobilize. They should have done it earlier. They have delayed the request of the British and the French to avoid provoking the Germans. That will cost them very dear,
里宾特洛普抵达帝国总理府，他说，看，英国没有丝毫让步的迹象。英国前线看起来相当黯淡。希特勒说，好吧，我已经下达了命令。齿轮在转动，事情正在进行。戈培尔那天下午在日记中写道，看起来骰子终于掷下了，这大概会很合你的胃口，汤姆。那天下午晚些时候，一个非常不祥的征兆，他们切断了柏林波兰大使馆内外的电话线。31日那天晚上11点，你得到了关于波兰边境发生冲突的第一批报告。最著名的一个发生在格利维采（现在上西里西亚的格利维采）的一个广播电台。所以这基本上是一个通常用于天气预报的广播电台。
I'm sorry to say. Can I just ask you, if they mobilise in the expectation that Britain and France will declare war on Germany, but more than that, that Britain and France will attack Germany in the West and that this would therefore give the Poles a fighting chance to, to survive. Do you think if they'd known that the British and French were actually going to do anything, but they were just going to kind of sit there? Might they have negotiated in that eventuality? No, I don't think so. I think they'd still have fought. I think they would probably still have fought. I think they can't conceive that the British and the French won't intervene. Right. Okay. So it's a non question.
有报道称波兰军队突袭了德国阵地，他们处决了工作人员并广播了波兰民族主义口号。实际上，发生的情况是，这次袭击是由党卫军组织的。这是由雷因哈德·海德里希直接策划的。袭击者和防守者都是党卫军成员，他们实际上发射的是空包弹。当他们离开时，他们留下了三具尸体。这些被称为罐头食品。罐头食品，完全正确。这就是行话。其中两个人是集中营
Yeah, but I think the British and the French have sent slightly mixed signals. They've sent a military mission. They've sent some sort of pretty pitiful supplies. The British and the French have been saying to them, you know, it'll be a long war. They've been sort of hinting that their intervention will not exactly be as game changing as the Poles might like. But Polish national pride, Polish public opinion, they make it will make it very, very difficult for any kind of compromise, I would say. So where are we? Thursday the 31st of August 1939. First thing that morning Hitler says to his generals, invasion will start tomorrow. He signs the attack order just after midday and then he confirms it an hour later. That afternoon, early that afternoon,
囚犯。他们被注射致死并穿上了波兰军服。第三个人是一个波兰人，一个波兰人，但他是一个德国公民。他是个当地农民，名叫弗朗西斯·西克·霍内奥克。他前一天被捕了。他以一个非常爱国的波兰人而闻名。他被逮捕，投入监狱，然后他被带出监狱，被注射安乐死。然后他被带到广播电台。然后他被枪杀，尸体被扔在那里。他是纳粹在未来六年里杀害的六百万波兰人中的第一个。
Ribbentrop arrives at the Reich Chancellery and he says, look, no give from Britain. It's looking pretty bleak on the British front. And Hitler says, well, I've already given the order. Dezacker Roller, things are rolling. And Goebbels writes in his diary that afternoon, it looks as if the die is finally cast and largely that will appeal to you Tom. And late that afternoon, a very ominous sign, they cut the telephone lines to and from the Polish embassy in Berlin. And at 11 o'clock that evening, the 31st, you have the first reports of incidents on the Polish frontier. The most famous one is at a radio station at a place called Gliwice, now Gliwice in Upper Silesia. So this was basically a radio station generally used for weather forecasting.
里宾特洛甫抵达帝国总理府，他说，看吧，英国人根本不让步。英国那边的情况看起来很不妙。希特勒则说，好吧，我已经下达了命令。事情已经开始滚动了。戈培尔那天下午在日记中写道，局势似乎终于尘埃落定了，这在很大程度上会合你的心意，汤姆。那天傍晚晚些时候，一个非常不祥的信号出现了，他们切断了柏林波兰大使馆的进出电话线。晚上11点，即31日那天，传来了波兰边境发生冲突的最早报告。最著名的一次发生在格利维采的一个广播电台，现在格利维采位于上西里西亚。所以这基本上是一个通常用于天气预报的广播电台。
And there were reports that Polish troops have stormed a German position, that they executed the staff and they broadcast Polish nationalist slogans. Actually, what happened was the attack was organized by the SS. It was planned directly by Reinhard Heydrich. Both the attackers and the defenders were SS men and they were actually firing blanks. And when they left, they left three bodies behind them. And these are called canned goods. Canned goods, exactly. Is the jargon. Two of these guys were concentration camp
有报道称，波兰军队突袭了一个德国阵地，他们处决了工作人员并广播了波兰民族主义口号。实际上，这次袭击是由党卫军组织的。它是直接由莱因哈德·海德里希策划的。进攻者和防守者都是党卫军成员，而且他们当时其实是在使用空包弹。当他们撤离时，留下了三具尸体。这些就是所谓的“罐头食品”。罐头食品，没错。这就是行话。其中两个人是集中营
inmates. They'd been killed with lethal injections and dressed in Polish uniforms. And the third man was a Pole, a Pole, but who was a German citizen. He was a local farmer and his name was Francis Sik, Honeok. And he had been arrested the day before. He was well known for being very patriotic Pole. And he was arrested, thrown into prison, and then he was taken out of prison and put to sleep with an injection. And then he was taken asleep to the radio station. And then he was shot dead and his body was dumped there. And he is the first of the six million Poles who will be killed by the Nazis in the next six years.
囚犯。他们被注射致死毒剂杀害，并穿上了波兰军服。第三个人是一个波兰人，一个波兰人，但他拥有德国国籍。他是一名当地农民，名叫弗朗西斯·西克·霍内奥克。他前一天就被捕了。他以热爱波兰而闻名。他被捕并投入监狱，然后被带出监狱并注射安眠药麻醉。接着他被带到那个广播电台。随后他被枪杀，尸体被丢弃在那里。他是未来六年内被纳粹杀害的六百万波兰人中的第一人。
So we'll get on to the fate of Poland in Monday's episode, but just to tie up this bit of the story. The war proper began at 4.45 the next morning, Friday the 1st of September, when an elderly German battleship called the Schleswig-Holstein opened fire on the Polish military depot on the Westerplatte, which is a peninsula that commands the entrance to Danzig's harbor. The same time that happened, 60 German divisions, about one and a half million men, spearheaded by tank divisions, began to cross the border, flood across the border from Germany into Poland. And by the afternoon of that day, Friday, you have the first reports of bombings, of Stuka attacks coming in from Western Poland and the Polish army is already beginning to fall back from the border.
所以我们将在周一的节目中讨论波兰的命运，但为了先理清故事的这一部分。真正的战争开始于第二天（9月1日，星期五）清晨4点45分，当时一艘老旧的德国战列舰“石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因号”向位于西盘半岛的波兰军事仓库开火，该半岛控制着但泽港的入口。与此同时，60个德国师，大约150万大军，以坦克师为先锋，开始跨越边境，从德国涌入波兰。到了那个星期五的下午，你就会听到来自波兰西部关于轰炸和斯图卡俯冲轰炸机袭击的最初报道，波兰军队已经开始从边境撤退。
Hitler addressed the Reichstag that morning at 10 o'clock. As you described, Tom, he was wearing his Wehrmacht uniform and he never takes it off for the, I mean, presumably takes off to sleep. A shower. Yeah. But he never dresses again in civilian clothes. And you did that performance with gusto because that's what we associate with Hitler. But actually, as we said, he was very nervous.
希特勒那天早上10点向帝国议会发表了讲话。正如你所描述的，汤姆，他穿着国防军制服，而且再也没有脱下来，我的意思是，大概睡觉时会脱下来洗个澡。是的。但他再也没有穿过便服。你充满激情地表演了那一段，因为那就是我们对希特勒的印象。但实际上，正如我们所说，他非常紧张。
He stumbled over his words. He's very downbeat. He gets the time wrong. And even that line, looking forward to his own death, is a hint, I think, at the doubts that must have been there, if only subconsciously. It was a very gloomy day in Berlin. There was no public enthusiasm at all. The American journalist William Shira described the, quote, astonishment, depression on the
他说话结结巴巴。他非常沮丧。他把时间记错了。甚至连那句期待自己死亡的话，我认为也是一种暗示，暗示他内心肯定存在的怀疑，哪怕只是潜意识里的。那在柏林是极其阴郁的一天。完全没有任何公众热情。美国记者威廉·夏伊尔形容当时……引用他的话……那种惊讶、沮丧……
faces of the people. No excitement, no hurrahs, no cheering, no throwing of flowers, no war fever, no war hysteria. Of course, they're all still waiting to find out what Britain and France will do. And Hitler did make one last attempt, another attempt through this Swedish guy, Dallarus. When Dallarus went to meet him at the Reich Chancellery, in Kershaw describes the scene in his biography, Hitler probably is a result of stress and tiredness. Not the gun oil. Not the gun oil. His breath was so repellent. The odour from his mouth was so strong that Dalaris was tempted to move back a step or two. So, you know, Hitler's
人们脸上的表情。没有兴奋，没有欢呼，没有喝彩，没有抛撒鲜花，没有战争狂热，没有战争歇斯底里。当然，他们都还在等待看英国和法国会采取什么行动。希特勒确实做了最后一次尝试，通过这个名叫达勒鲁斯的瑞典人进行了又一次尝试。当达勒鲁斯去帝国总理府见他时，克肖在传记中描述了当时的场景：希特勒可能是因为压力和疲劳。不是枪油的味道。不是枪油的味道。他的口气太难闻了。他嘴里散发的气味如此强烈，以至于达勒鲁斯差点想退后一两步。所以，你知道，希特勒的...
hygiene has kind of collapsed. And Hitler says, you know, tell the British, give this as their last chance to avoid a fight with me. I'll fight them for 10 years if I need to, which is not very... Yeah, it's not very emollient. Not very emollient and obviously doesn't work. The next day, the second Britain and France by now had ordered full mobilization, they begin evacuating children from the cities. Chamberlain is in talks about drawing up a war cabinet, bringing Winston Churchill back as first Lord of the Admiralty. And that evening is the
个人卫生已经有些崩溃了。希特勒说，你知道的，告诉英国人，把这当作他们避免与我一战的最后机会。如果需要的话，我会跟他们打十年仗，这可真算不上……是的，一点也不温和。一点也不温和，显然也没有起作用。第二天，即英法两国此时已经下令全面动员的第二天，他们开始从城市疏散儿童。张伯伦正在就组建战时内阁进行会谈，将温斯顿·丘吉尔重新请回担任第一海军大臣。那天晚上是……
evening of the very famous debate. Chamberlain gives, as he so often does, a very ill-judged speech in which he says, if the Germans pull back from Poland, maybe we could still talk to them. What a mad thing to say. And this is the moment at which famously, as the Labour leader Arthur Greenwood stands up to reply, one of Churchill's allies called Leo Amory shouts, speak for England Arthur. And this is a great shock to Chamberlain. The sense that he's lost touch with the public, with many of his own party. And indeed with his own cabinet, because afterwards his cabinet say to him, look enough, you've got to give an ultimatum. And Henderson goes to give the ultimatum first
那场非常著名的辩论之夜。张伯伦像往常一样发表了一篇很不合时宜的演讲，他在演讲中说，如果德国人从波兰撤军，也许我们还能跟他们谈谈。这是多么疯狂的话啊。就在这时，正如工党领袖亚瑟·格林伍德起身回应时那句著名的插话，丘吉尔的盟友之一利奥·阿默里大喊：“为了英国发言吧，亚瑟。”这对张伯伦来说是一个巨大的打击。他感觉到自己已经脱离了公众，脱离了自己党内的许多人。甚至脱离了他自己的内阁，因为事后他的内阁对他说，听着，够了，你必须发出最后通牒。而亨德森去发出最后通牒是在……
thing the next morning. So Sunday the 3rd of September, nine o'clock in the morning, Henderson goes to the foreign ministry in Berlin, ribbonbentrop. Do you remember when we did the series on the first world war? All those scenes of the ambassadors crying and foreign ministers shaking hands and the sense- None of that now. ... really kind of moving actually, really moving. Well, Ribbentrop is cut from very different cloth. He will not even meet Henderson. He refuses even to see him. And Henderson gets interned, doesn't he?
第二天一大早。所以是9月3日星期日，早上九点，亨德森前往柏林的外交部，见里宾特洛甫。还记得我们做第一次世界大战系列节目的时候吗？那些大使们哭泣、外交官们握手的场景，以及那种感觉——现在可没有这些了。……其实挺感人的，真的很感人。好吧，里宾特洛甫完全是另一类人。他甚至不愿意见亨德森。他甚至拒绝见他。而亨德森被扣留了，对吧？
He doesn't need to get cleared. So Henderson has to make do with the interpreter, Paul Schmidt. So he gives him the ultimatum as surely everybody listening to this podcast will know the ultimatum expired at 11 o'clock. The Germans didn't reply. And a few minutes later, Chamberlain made that very famously gloomy speech. Yeah, and no such undertaking has been received. And consequently, this country is at war with Germany. You know, announcing the beginning of the Second World War for Britain and for France. But let's end with the interpreter,
他不需要被放行。所以亨德森只能将就着由翻译保罗·施密特代劳。于是他向他递交了最后通牒，正如听这个播客的每个人肯定都知道的那样，最后通牒于11点到期。德国人没有回复。几分钟后，张伯伦发表了那篇非常著名的阴郁演讲。是的，而且没有收到任何这样的保证。因此，这个国家与德国处于战争状态。你知道的，这宣告了英国和法国第二次世界大战的开始。但让我们以翻译来结束……
Paul Schmidt. He said, I took the ultimatum to the chancellery where everyone was anxiously awaiting me. There was something of a crush and I had difficulty in getting through to Hitler. When I entered, Hitler was sitting at his desk and Ribbentrop stood by the window. Both looked up expectantly as I came in. I stopped at some distance from Hitler's desk and then I slowly translated the British government's ultimatum. When I finished, there was complete silence. Hitler sat immobile, gazing before him. He was not at a loss, as was afterwards stated, nor did he rage, as others allege. He sat completely silent and unmoving. After an interval which seemed an age, he turned to Ribbentrop, who'd remained standing by the window. And Hitler asked, what now?
保罗·施密特。他说：“我把最后通牒带到总理府，所有的人都在那里焦急地等待着我。现场有些拥挤，我费了好大劲才挤到希特勒面前。当我走进去时，希特勒正坐在他的办公桌前，里宾特洛甫站在窗边。我进来时，两人都期待地抬起头。我在离希特勒办公桌有一段距离的地方停下来，然后我慢慢地翻译了英国政府的最后通牒。当我讲完时，是一片死寂。希特勒一动不动地坐着，凝视着前方。他并没有不知所措，正如后来所说的那样，也没有暴跳如雷，正如其他人所声称的那样。他完全静静地坐着，一动不动。在一段仿佛过了一个世纪的间歇之后，他转向一直站在窗边的里宾特洛甫。希特勒问：‘现在怎么办？’
What now? What now, indeed? We will be back on Monday to find out what happened next. We'll be doing the story of Poland's heroic resistance, doomed resistance, and the tragedy of its fall and its fate. And if you're a member of the Restless History Club, you can hear that episode right now. But for now, thank you, Dominic. Brilliant stuff. Goodbye. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在怎么办？确实，现在怎么办？我们将在周一回来，看看接下来发生了什么。我们将讲述波兰英勇抵抗、注定失败的抵抗，以及其陷落和命运的悲剧。如果你是“动荡历史俱乐部”的会员，你现在就可以收听那一集。但现在，谢谢你，多米尼克。精彩的内容。再见。再见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。